Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Es ist warm.
Ja, wir sind in der Garderobe, gleich geht es an den Live-Salon. Wir wollen aber erst einmal ankündigen, was wir als nächstes lesen werden. Und zwar dachten wir, nachdem du dich so intensiv mit dem Männer-Podcast beschäftigt hast, sollten wir auch den Autor eines Podcasts an den Mittelpunkt drücken, nämlich Robin Alexander. Der hat ein Buch geschrieben, das für uns, glaube ich, besonders relevant ist, weil wir so viel über die AfD gesprochen haben aus einer Perspektive, die jetzt die ganze Zeit sich fragt, was muss von links getan werden, um die AfD zu verhindern? Jetzt schreibt Robin Alexander ein Buch, das heißt Letzte Chance, was jetzt die CDU gerade machen muss, um die Demokratie zu retten, um die AfD zu verhindern. Also für Robin Alexander ist klar, dass also nur über eine gewisse CDU, wie sie dann aussieht, wird er uns vorstellen. Es möglich ist, die AfD zu stoppen. Ich glaube, diesen Perspektivwechsel einzunehmen scheint sinnvoll.
Ja, genau, Perspektivwechsel. Ich halte das nämlich für dann wahrscheinlich eine sehr streitbare Lektüre.
Ich denke auch.
Wir hören, dass nur noch die CDU uns vor der AfD beschützen kann.
Genau.
Da hat man schon ganz viele Ideen von, wir brauchen konstruktive Angebote entweder pragmatisch oder ideologisch abgeräumt.
Ja.
Also begeben wir uns mal in diese Tiefen.
Es ist noch einmal auch so eine Analyse, glaube ich, für uns. Vielleicht das letzte Mal so eine Analyse des Konservatismus im Sinne von wir dürfen konservativ sein, aber es darf keine Partei rechts zur CDU geben. Also ich glaube, das ist nochmal so einmal der Versuch, dieses Konzept nochmal stark zu machen.
Aber wenn das schon so heißt, die letzte Chance, dann ist das für uns auch die letzte Chance. Ich denke, ob dann nochmal was zu holen ist aus der CDU.
Ja, und das führt uns eigentlich schon zu unserem Live-Salon heute. Es ist ein bisschen anders. Wir sind etwas politiklastiger heute, aber es ist so viel in der Welt, dass wir dachten, wir müssen jetzt auch mal jetz als des Klamauks über sehr relevante Dinge sprechen und zwar über die AfD. Und zwar hat Maximilian Krah in Schnellroda die Kubitscheks besucht und mit denen über die Strategie der AfD diskutiert. Und die Kubitscheks werfen Krah vor, dass er ja jetzt so ein Liberaler wird oder nicht mehr so richtig an eine Migration glaubt und was ist denn da eigentlich los. Man hat viele Fragen an Krah und wir werden jetzt sehr schön sehen können, wie Maximilian Krah, Staatsvolk und ethnisches Volk, wie er das versteht, wie er Staatsbürgerschaft versteht. Und eine These jetzt von mir, also es sind viele Dinge, die wir ansprechen werden, eine These von mir ist, woran jetzt Maximilian Krah arbeitet, ist tatsächlich die Normalisierung der AfD. Und zwar nicht im Sinne von unsere Normalisierung, wir laden den Talkshow ein oder so, sondern die AfD normalisiert sich auch selbst. Man könnte sagen, sie zähmt sich ein bisschen, aber in gewisser Weise wird sie jetzt noch gefährlicher im Sinne von wird sie gewählt werden. Und das ist also eine eine hoch interessante Debatte.
Genau, denn wenn Robin Alexander's letzte Chance vertan ist, ist es die erste Chance für Jens Schwan. Ja, das ist das große Projekt. Wir gucken heute außerdem auch Hoss & Hopf. Sie haben eine große Live-Show gemacht, vier Stunden lang. Da steckt nichts drin. Wir hören nur einen kleinen Ausschnitt. Jemand war ja maulwurfartig vor Ort und hat uns Audio-Material dargelassen. Aber wie gesagt, das schauen wir nur beispielhaft, um zu sagen, da steckt nichts drin. Aber im Podcast, wir machen heute, wir haben euch den Grundbegriff schon gefunden, den Synchrotismus. Was ist, wenn man eine große Linie einfach umdeutet, eine große historische Linie einfach umdeutet? Das wird in diesem Podcast gemacht. Und ich glaube, wenn man das historische Programm der Semantik gegenüberstellt, ist es auch ein bisschen amüsant. Für Live-Publikum genau richtig, glaube ich. Dann Polen. Wir haben eine Präsidentenwahl in Polen gehabt, die mit 0,8 Prozent oder so entschieden wurde. Und meine These ist, es war Dobrindt, Merz und Dobrindt. Die sind schuld. Und das lässt sich aus deutschem Nachrichtenmaterial auch, finde ich, sehr eindeutig heraus hören. Es ist nur die Frage, wie offen ist man das, wie offen ist man für das Argument zu sagen, im Grunde brauchen wir keine LA-Berichterstattung, um uns darüber zu ereifern, was hier gerade passiert, sondern wir sehen das auch in Deutschland mit den Zurückweisungen. Nur haben wir unseren politischen Gorilla noch contained. Wir haben keine Demokraten in Kalifornien, die einfach einen Niedriglohnsektor so bereitet haben, dass sie allen so ärgern dürfen, zu bleiben, aus dem Goodwill und dann plötzlich regieren die anderen und die haben kein Goodwill und alle sind vogelfrei. In Deutschland haben wir noch ein Grundgesetz und Gerichte, die funktionieren. Und plötzlich hat man Politik in gleicher Intensität, aber noch hinter Gitter. Mal gucken, wie lange noch.
Wir beenden den Abend dann mit Mathias Döpfner. Der hat nämlich ein Personality-Interview gegeben und wir sehen ja in ihm den Milliardär, den Konzernchef, den Medienmacher, das Vorbild, der Zeitungspräsident. Ja, aber er möchte als Mensch gesehen werden. Und das werden wir heute mal tun. Natürlich nicht nur, um uns nochmal mit Döpfner zu beschäftigen und uns ein bisschen lustig zu machen, sondern wirklich, um nochmal genau diese Ideologie bloßzulegen, dass da Leute jetzt immer mehr kommen in die Podcast hinein, migrieren und sagen, hallo, ich würde jetzt gerne mal nur über mich sprechen und meine Kindheit und meine Mutter und so weiter.
Wenn einer Menschen sieht in dieser Welt, dann da wohl Matze Hilschmann.
Ja, also auch das muss heute besprochen werden. Und all das kann man ganz einfach hören, nämlich wenn man uns abonniert. Das ist möglich, wenn man Apple-Kunde ist und wir da auch die Apple-Welt nicht verlassen, dann kann man das einfach im Shop anklicken und kommt dann zu diesem Live-Salon und auch zu allen anderen Salons. Sonst kann man die 2-Stunden-Show natürlich auch sehen, wenn man uns über Patreon oder Steady abonniert. Wir referieren Steady. Da kommt man ganz einfach hin. Man geht auf unsere Seite neu20er.de. Da ist ein goldener Button. Da klickt man drauf und dann kann man ein Abo abschließen und hat dann Zugang zu allen regulären Salons und natürlich auch zu den Lives heraus.
So ist es.
Dann gehen wir mal hinaus.
Dann gehen wir mal hinaus. Es ist nicht mehr so heiß wie sonst. Ich wollte einen Scherz machen in die Hölle, aber nein. Wir haben es sehr klimatisiert, sehr gut klimatisiert. Bis gleich.
Guten Abend. Guten Abend.
Macht ihr uns ein bisschen weniger Licht, damit wir noch am Anfang zumindest mehr sehen. Es scheint wahnsinnig gesundes Publikum zu sein, denn so wenig Hinweise auf ich muss mein Ticket noch loswerden und so gab es nie. Also ihr seid alle topfit und die Hitze macht euch auch nichts. Das ist ja gut. Und uns auch nicht.
Es wird nicht ganz so lange wie der Parsifal. Gestern waren ja schon einige mit im Parsifal in der Oper. Es hat fünf Stunden gedauert, also eine ganz typische Neue-Zwanziger-Folge. Jetzt natürlich nur zwei Stunden.
Wer war denn mit dabei?
Ja, hier sind so ein paar. Und, hat es dir gefallen?
Ja, klar.
Ja, ich hatte ja mit der Inszenierung meine Schwierigkeiten, will es dir aber nicht ausführen. Aber es war musikalisch beeindruckend.
Ihr seht mich schlotternd. Wolfgang hat mir eben kurz gesagt, er hat eine Frage zu passen.
Ja, ich frage dich jetzt, der vielleicht berühmteste Satz neben Zum Raum wird hier die Zeit ist ja, die Wunde schließt der Sperr nur, der sie schlug. Und ist das eigentlich unser Motto in diesem Podcast? Denn wir bringen immer schreckliche Leute mit, um uns dann von denen zu lösen oder zu reinigen.
Also gestern war ein sehr großer Fallos auf der Bühne in Form eines Sperrs, damit es nicht zu anstößig ist. Der wurde natürlich hin und her geschwungen und so weiter. Und dieses Bild des Sperrs habe ich auch häufiger in meinen Texten verwendet, wenn ich nämlich sage, und da saß der Interviewgast, der den Sperr zurückwarf, wie er zu ihm geflogen kam. Und so ein bisschen machen wir das heute auch. Also wir haben heute Krah, Hoss und Hopf und Döpfner, Kubitschek, also heute volle Packung. Und wenn du Patewal zitierst, ich war am Dienstag ja auch in der Oper, in Melusine, du hast sie verpasst. Der tollste Satz, der da auch auf Deutsch gesungen wurde, war, ich versuche mein Schicksal zu entziffern. Dafür sind wir heute hier, wir entziffern heute unser Schicksal.
Wunderbar, dann legen wir los.
Dominik, typischerweise sehen wir das Publikum immer so ein bisschen mehr. Vielleicht können wir es doch auf Dauer, vor allem die hier, so ein bisschen dunkler machen vielleicht. Also Kronleuchter an ist sehr gut und hier vorne so ein bisschen. Ja, das ist gut. Das ist gut, sonst wird man hier abends auch noch geblendet. Das wäre zu viel. Also Hoss & Hopf. Wer freut sich am meisten auf Hoss & Hopf? Oder sollen wir erst Krah oder erst Kubitschek oder?
Hoss & Hopf. Diese Sache entstand ja so, ich kenne ja die Clips noch nicht, aber du hast mir erzählt, du sitzt da auf deinem Fahrrad, das du dir gekauft hast. Also jetzt so ein Homebike, tremelst eifrig und hörst und siehst dir dann alles an, was du immer mal hören und sehen wolltest.
Aber da nicht Hoss & Hopf. Hoss & Hopf höre ich in dreifacher Geschwindigkeit, während ich mit ganz viel anderen Sachen zu tun habe. Auf dem Fahrrad konzentriere ich mich und gucke Arte. Der Arteanteil, der gleich kommt, das ist sozusagen der konstruktive, kreative, körperliche Anteil. Hoss & Hopf ist das, was ich so dem beigehört habe. Ihr wisst aber auch, dass Hoss & Hopf auf der Bühne waren. Zum Beispiel in der Langsess-Arena. Es gibt Audioaufnahmen von dort, die uns zugespielt wurden, die wirklich wahnsinnig interessant sind. Und damit möchte ich schon den ersten Scherz einleiten. Denn es war alles andere als interessant. Ich habe das Transkript. Ich habe versucht, so ein bisschen aus dem Hall mal rauszuhören. Also diese Veranstaltung kostet 80 Euro oder 70 so. Ab 70. 80. Und dauerte vier Stunden. Und wir hören jetzt für eine Minute rein. Viel Glück.
Was ich bei Wohnorten meine, es gibt sogenannte Baubiologen. Das heißt, ich teile das Schlafzimmer, Küche, Wohnzimmer und so weiter rein. Und dann mache ich eine Liste. Okay, was ist ein Potenzial im Schlafzimmer, was man im Schlaf nicht optimieren kann? Ist vielleicht Schimmel an den Wänden? Ist vielleicht Schimmel oder Staub im Teppich? Weil es gibt so viele Dinge, die man noch optimieren kann. Vielleicht einen Satz von dir, den von euch beiden, was ihr da schon macht, oder was du sagst, okay, das ist Gamsmolken.
Was ich mache?
Ja, oder was vielleicht Gamsmolken, Alpen und Drogen natürlich.
Und natürlich nicht. Was ich auf jeden Fall mache, ist Fluorid aus dem Zahnpasta raus. Weil Fluorid ist ein Erfengift. Das ist auch immer ein interessantes Thema, weil du redest mit Zahnärzten, die durch ein Medizinsstudium gegangen sind und die natürlich dann von dieser Quelle auch genährt werden. Die dann sagen, nein, das ist überhaupt nicht so. Aber wenn du dich mal weiter informierst, das ist das Allerwichtigste Mal, das ist auch nicht schwierig. Ich suche dir nach einer facken Zahnpasta ohne Fluorid.
Das ist ganz simpel.
Und auf was ich wirklich... Also Wasser, ihr wisst, Kian und ich haben früher einen Wasserpodcast gemacht und mal darüber gesprochen, dass wir auch ganz massiv angegriffen wurden. Seitdem ist schon mehrmals rausgekommen, Leitungswasser massiv belastet. Und damals haben sie uns auch angegriffen. Wir könnt ihr nur so ein Blödsinn behaupten, dass man das Leitungswasser nicht mehr trinken soll. Auf jeden Fall. Ich würde keinen Leitungswasser trinken. Außer ich lebe vielleicht in Österreich, in den Bergen oder in der Schweiz.
Das Wichtigste, was ich euch mitgeben kann, Leute, ist wirklich soziales Umfeld.
Ja, weiß ich, wie sich da dann noch einstellt im sozialen Umfeld.
Also das ist Hoss & Hopf. Vier Stunden ging das so. Schön. Das war jetzt eine Minute von 60 mal vier.
Aber auch so ganz praktische Lebensberatung. Also von der Zahnpasta bis zum Bettgenossen. Alles wird mal geklärt.
Genau. Also ich hätte gerne eine ganze Clip-Show draus gemacht, aber ich zitiere einfach nur, ich gehe kurz die Liste durch. Bitte kein Plastik in der Unterhose. Man hat Schweinesversuche gemacht und Plastik an den Hoden führt zu 100% Verlust der Spermengqualität.
Nur 100% Baumwolle tragen.
Falls ihr euch einkriemt, cremt sich ja jemand ein. Einer nur, sag mal. Ja, womit? Also, ja. Ab sofort bitte nur noch mit Sachen einkriemen, die ihr auch essen würdet. Ganz wichtiger Tipp von Hoss & Hopf.
Ich sehe mich jetzt gerade, wie ich so meine Clarinstube esse morgen früh.
Und falls ihr mal wieder eine Primärerfahrung machen wollt, ihr wisst, was eine Primärerfahrung ist, Sachen, die man noch nie gemacht hat. Es gibt hier Primärerfahrung für erwachsene Männer. Denn eine Studie besagt, ab 30 Jahren springen weniger als 5% der Männer überhaupt noch einmal in ihrem Leben.
Springen?
Also hüpfen. Falls euch mehr interessiert, schickt mir eine E-Mail, ich kann euch die vier Stunden zuleiten. Ansonsten, falls ihr noch offene Wünsche habt, ich möchte kurz vorlesen. Aus dem Transkript. Es gibt Menschen, die schreiben einfach nur, schreibe es runter, schreibe es runter und dann glauben sie, hier finden sich irgendwie riesige Dinge auf. Also, wer sich was wünscht und manifestieren möchte, nicht einfach nur aufschreiben, denn, ne, so funktioniert das nicht. Ihr müsst es selber auch fühlen. Macht eure Augen zu, stellt euch vor, wie ihr euch fühlt, wenn es soweit ist.
Ich habe einen Auszug gesehen, nicht von unserem Spion, sondern von jemand anderem, bei Instagram. Und zwar wurde bei einer Veranstaltung von Hoss & Hopf dann auch eine Reise nach Dubai verlost. Und dann kam ein junger Mann auf die Bühne, der diese Reise gewonnen hatte. Und er hatte auch gleich eine Begründung dafür, dass er sie gewonnen hat, denn er hat die ganze Zeit, während er da unten saß, gedacht, ich muss die Reise gewinnen, hat das manifestiert und siehe da, es hat funktioniert. Was natürlich bedeutet, die anderen haben unten im Publikum einfach nicht gut genug manifestiert. Sonst hätten wir auch alle eine Reise gewonnen. Ja, sehr logisch.
Aber die anderen 50.000 haben auch gesehen, dass es prinzipiell funktioniert. Ja, ich habe auch so ein anderes Video gesehen, da wurde zusammengefasst, das waren vier sehr coole Typen, die sind ungefähr wie wir beide zur Gamescom gefahren, also vor Freude, ab das Auto fährt los und so. Und dann haben sie aber vor Ort festgestellt, dass es eigentlich nicht so für sie ist. Und haben sich das dann schön geredet, indem sie sich das so validieren, im Sinne von, das hilft bestimmt voll vielen hier voll gut, aber wir sind schon beide. Aber es war trotzdem voll gut. Ja, aber wir bleiben trotzdem bei Hoss & Hopf. Wir gucken nur nicht in diese Stadion Tour rein. Wir machen das jetzt so. Ich habe Videomaterial mit. Wir gucken einen Podcast. Das heißt ja hier Podcast. Hoss sitzt ja, nee, Hopf sitzt in der Schweiz, ist in einem Podcast aufgenommen. Und während wir jetzt Hoss reden hören und Hopf aber sehen, ihr kennt ja das Prinzip des körperlichen Nachvollzugs, also man sieht etwas und denkt sich so die ganze Zeit, ist das jetzt vorbildhaft, soll ich das auch machen, muss ich ihm nacheinfallen, ist ja mein Vorbild und so weiter. Wir überlegen uns jetzt, wie es aussähe, würde sich Wolfgang wie Philip Hopf im Podcast verhalten, während ich die Einführung spreche. Aber trotzdem auch ein bisschen innerlich zuhören, ja. Denn das ist jetzt auch thematisch für uns, nicht ganz unbedeutend, was hier gesagt wird. Also hier Hoss & Hopf aus irgendwann im Frühjahr.
Rockefeller, ein Name, der den meisten einbegriff sein wird, einer der mächtigsten und wohlhabendsten Familien der Weltgeschichte. Wir wollen uns heute die 38 Briefe und vor allem die 15 Lehren, die sich daraus ableiten lassen, die Rockefeller damals an seinen Sohn John D. Rockefeller jr. geschrieben hat, zusammen anschauen und uns hoffentlich etwas daraus mitnehmen für unser eigenes Leben. Herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen Podcast Hoss & Hopf.
Danke schön. Da werden mal die Flusen noch vom Hemd genommen und dann geht es los. Übrigens habe ich mir sagen lassen von jemandem, bevor die so groß wurden, die ich schon mal getroffen habe, also den Hoss. Und Hoss muss der richtig erfolgreiche sein. Also der hat wohl, also da, ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie hoch die Summen sind. Also Hoss ist der, der, der Multi-Multi-Multi-Millionär. Während bei Hopf offenbar das mit dem Manifestieren noch nicht so erfolgreich war. Also er ist finanziell schlechter gestellt. Da müsste er sich ja eigentlich auch mal Gedanken machen.
Also wir können ja kurz hier in das Video mal zurückspringen. Man sieht das auch ein bisschen an den Uhren.
Ah ja.
Klar Größe ist nicht alles, aber ich würde auch sagen, der Hoss ist hier der Größere. Ja, gut, wir gucken das. Also die beiden haben jetzt gesagt, sie wollen über Rockefeller reden. Rockefeller, der reiste Mann in der Erde damals, vielleicht historisch die reiste Figur ever. Der hat ja Briefe an seinen Sohn geschrieben, wie man sich so richtig verhält. Ist voll der tolle Typ, volles Vorbild. Außer man macht Sport auf so einem Fahrrad indo und kann währenddessen Arte gucken. Da erfährt man nämlich anderes. Wir sehen hier schon so eine Krake. In dem Falle kein antisemitisches Bild, sondern das ist Öl, Standard Oil. Und die Krake umschlingt Amerika. Man sieht ja auch den Kongress und das Weiße Haus und so weiter. Und im Text läuft so.
Indem er dem Land sein Monopol aufgezwungen hat, ist Rockefeller zum meistgehassten Mann Amerikas geworden. In seiner Residenz in Cleveland, immer eine Bibel zur Hand, ist er der Meinung, niemandem Rechenschaft schuldig zu sein, außer Gott.
Ja, der meistgehasste Mann Amerikas, der sich nur noch Gott verantwortlich fühlt.
Kennen wir, wir haben mal Mark Zuckerberg gehört, der sagte, ja, ich kommuniziere immer noch, aber mit Gott.
Ja, nun fragen wir uns, Momentchen mal, da sitzt jemand in Dubai, einer der Schweiz, die reden dann immer über den Amerikaner, warum ist das jetzt für uns bedeutend?
Es geht um John Davison Rockefeller, der wurde 1839 in Ridgeford, New York, als zweites von sechs Kindern geboren. Seine Familie hatte deutsche Wurzeln und der Name Rockefeller, für die, die es gar nicht wissen, stammt vom Ort Rockenfeld in Rheinland-Pfalz.
Das ist unsere Konvention.
15 Kilometer von mir entfernt.
Siehst du mal. Siehst du mal, also es ist jetzt quasi Heimatkunde für dich.
Prinzip, ja.
Also wir gehen mal die Lebensregeln durch. Hier zum Beispiel, wir können es uns ungefähr denken.
Fangen wir an mit den Lehren. Also wie gesagt, er hat 38 Briefe insgesamt an seinen Sohn geschrieben und daraus lassen sich 15 wichtige Lehren ableiten, die uns im heutigen Leben noch helfen können. Die erste ist, unser Schicksal hängt von unseren Taten ab, nicht von unserer Herkunft. Und ich glaube, das ist etwas, das klingt zwar immer mal wieder Klischee, aber es deutet sich und lässt sich ausdrücken in der Einschränkung, die man sich selber in seinen Kopf setzt, wenn man sagt, ich komme aus einem kleinen Dorf, deswegen werde ich niemals xy erreichen. Ich bin in so eine Familie geboren. Wir haben dieses Familienbusiness. Deswegen muss ich dem weiter nachgehen. Ich habe keine Finanzen oder Wirtschaftshintergründe. Wir haben keine Ärzte in der Familie. Deswegen kann ich diese Berufszweige gar nicht erst erklimmen. All das schränkt einen nur in seinem eigenen Gehirn ein. Und deswegen ist es eben wichtig zu erkennen, dass man von Anfang an dieses Framework in seinem Kopf, davon, wo ich herkomme, den Job, den ich ausführe, das ist so, wie es halt ist. Mein Leben ist innerhalb dieser Regeln komplett über Bord wirft und sagt Nein. Wenn ich mich in eine gewisse Richtung entwickeln möchte, ist das Einzige, was dafür relevant ist, die Taten, die ich in diese Richtung vollziehe und nicht, woher ich eigentlich komme und welche Regeln ich mir in meinen Kopf gesetzt habe.
Ja, also lass dich nicht von deinem Kopf einsperren im Gefängnis deiner Herkunft, sondern, ja, was denn eigentlich? Erkunde die Welt, steig ins Flüchtlingsboot, fahr nach Europa und mach einen großen Baccar. Nee, das ist ja eigentlich ein Podcast, der uns das Gegenteil erzählt. Also ursprünglich wollte ich das eigentlich unter einer anderen Paralleiter aufzeigen.
Das ist ja das Interessante. Wenn man diese Idee ja ganz ernst nimmt, und es gibt ja jemanden, der das getan hat, nämlich Milton Friedman oder auch jemand wie Hayek, die sind ja davon ausgegangen, dass Migration gut ist und dass sie sogar auch eine gewisse Sympathie für illegale Migration, für sogenannte illegale Migration hatten, weil sie sagen ja, die Leute, die haben ja wirklich Biss, die da kommen. Also die lösen sich ja. Und das Versprechen der Moderne ist ja eigentlich, löse dich aus deinem Kaff, Rockenfeld oder wo auch immer. Und du kannst alles sein. Und das Medium Geld macht es für dich auch möglich, dass du überall zahlen kannst und dass du deine Arbeitskraft überall verkaufen kannst, löst dich auch aus allen feudalen Zusammenhängen. Und das ist ja zunächst einmal richtig so, aber bedeutet eben ja diese doppelte Freiheit, nämlich einmal frei zu sein von Produktionsmitteln, also nichts zu haben und bedeutet natürlich dann auch die Freiheit zu haben, irgendwo hinzugehen, klar.
So und jetzt haben wir ja einen Grundbegriff gelernt beim letzten Mal, Synkretismus war das, glaube ich. Also man hat eigentlich schon so eine geschrieben Geschichte und denkt sich, nee, sorry, das ist super eindeutig und dann kommt einer und deutet es doch um. Ja, also wie das Außenministerium da, das plötzlich so eine Linie zieht von Sokrates bis Trump und so. Und wir wollen das jetzt hier auch mal überprüfen. Also die lesen diesen Brief, den Rockefeller an seinen Sohn schreibt, wo drin steht, mache dich frei von deiner Herkunft. Wir überprüfen jetzt die Geschichtsschreibung laut Arte, der wir mehr vertrauen und gucken mal, wie das in der Biografie Rockefellers sich so niedergeschlagen hat, diese Lebensweisheit von Herrn Rockefeller selbst.
Ms. Abby Aldrich, Tochter des Senators Nelson Aldrich und John Rockefeller jr., einziger Sohn von John D. Rockefeller, haben heute in der Sommerresidenz von Senator Aldrich geheiratet.
Nelson Aldrich, nunmehr Schwiegervater von Rockefeller jr., ist der Mehrheitsführer der Republikaner im Senat. Kein Bundesgesetz kann ohne seine Zustimmung verabschiedet werden. Er ist so mächtig, dass die Zeitungen ihn als Generalmanager der Nation bezeichnen. Mit der Vereinigung ihrer Nachkommen verfolgen der reichste Mann der Welt und der einflussreichste Politiker Washingtons eine traditionelle Klassenstrategie. Und legen den Grundstein für eine Dynastie, die Amerika über Generationen hinweg beherrschen wird. Rockefeller Enkel stellen drei Gouverneure, einen Chef der größten Investmentbank Amerikas und einen Vizepräsidenten der Vereinigten Staaten.
Mach dich frei von deiner Herkunft. Also mehr Dynastie gab es nicht mal im Mittelalter. Aber gut, also ganz wichtig, Herkunft, ganz unbedeutend. Jetzt wird es ein bisschen heikel. Hoss stellt die nächste Lebensregel vor. Manche Leute haben so falsches Denken, ist ja klar, aus der Richtung sowieso. Wir hören das hier mal, es hat so einen klaren materiellen Einschlag.
Zu viele Leute überschätzen die Relevanz dessen, was ihnen fehlt, aber unterschätzen das, was sie haben und mitbringen. Dadurch werden sie zu verlieren. Das ist leider so satirisch, wie es klingt, sehr, sehr wahr.
So, zu viele Menschen überschätzen, was sie wollen und unterschätzen, was sie haben. Kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen, das ist die Ansage eines Kapitaleigners an die Arbeiterschaft, die plötzlich irgendwas will, wie Gewerkschaftsarbeit, höhere Löhne, weniger Arbeitszeit oder so. Ey, unterschätzt doch voll, was ihr habt und überhöht doch, was ihr wollt. Schlägt sich historisch so nieder. Also es wird quasi eins zu eins, was hier reflektiert wird bei Arte.
Im April 1914 sind die Bergarbeiter in Ludlow, Colorado seit Monaten im Streik. Sie fordern die Anerkennung ihrer Gewerkschaft, was Rockefeller jr., der Hauptaktionär der Mine, ablehnt. Die zumeist mitteleuropäischen Migranten sprechen kaum Englisch und besitzen nicht die amerikanische Staatsbürgerschaft.
Ja, da sind also Leute, die wollen was von diesem Rockefeller. Und die wissen gar nicht zu schätzen, was es da im Angebot ist.
Was sie schon haben.
Ja, was eben bedeutet, wenn es so konfrontativ wird, Beharrlichkeit. Jetzt muss Beharrlichkeit her.
Und ihr seht hier ein John D. Rockefeller als ehemals reichster Mensch der Welt zu seiner damaligen Zeit. Geht hier nicht auf Intelligenz ein oder auf Talent. Viele Leute, das ist ja auch ein Punkt, den sie sich sagen. Sie sagen entweder ich habe nicht die Connections, ich kenne nicht die Leute, die erfolgreich sind. Ich bin nicht intelligent genug. Ich habe nicht diese Bildung. Keines dieser Punkte hier wird erwähnt. Ja, das sollte ein maßgeblicher Punkt sein. Für all die Menschen, die jetzt gerade zuhören und die sagen, ja gut, ich komme nicht aus Reichel und Elternhaus, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, einfach shut the fuck up und sagt euch nur eines, ihr braucht Beharrlichkeit und Durchhaltevermögen. Das sind zwei Worte, die sind sich sehr ähnlich in der Ausdrehung. Das bedeutet einfach, wenn ihr scheitert, dann bleibt ihr nicht liegen, sondern ihr steht sofort wieder offen, macht weiter. Und wenn ihr eine Aufgabe angeht, dann hört ihr nicht auf mit dieser Aufgabe, bis sie vollendet ist. Darum geht es wirklich. Das ist die Singulär wichtigste Tugend, die ein Mensch haben kann, ist Beharrlichkeit. Es ist nicht Talent, es ist nicht Intelligenz. Es ist sonst gar nichts anderes. Ein dummer Mensch kann steinreich werden, aber ein intelligenter Mensch wird nicht immer reich. So viele Hochschulprofessoren, die super gebildet sind, absolute Intellektuelle, die ihr ganzes Leben mit dem Studium verbringen, werden niemals reich. Da müssten sie doch aber eigentlich, wenn es an der Intelligenz liegt, hat aber damit nichts zu tun, sondern Beharrlichkeit. Immer an der Sache dranbleiben. Niemals aufgeben. Wie ein Wildschwein, das durch ein Feld durch sich durchwühlt. Also müsst ihr euch das vorstellen. Ihr wühlt euch durch, bis der Erfolg erzwungener Maßen zu euch kommt.
So.
Aber ich finde irgendwie scheinbar, das zählt mich an.
Wie ein Wildschwein durch das Lager pflügen. Jetzt fragt man sich ein bisschen, für wen gilt das jetzt? Für denjenigen, der den Streik da auflösen möchte, mit allen Mitteln beharrlich, wie auch immer, oder für diejenigen, die ihre Rechte da durchsetzen wollen. Ist in dem Falle historisch natürlich eindeutig.
Die Soldaten stürmen das Lager der Streikenden und setzen es in Brand. Sie erschießen 13 fliehende Bergarbeiter. Und in den Trümmern werden die verkohlten Überreste von 11 Kindern und 2 Frauen entdeckt. Am nächsten Tag fordert eine wütende Menschenmenge vor dem New Yorker Hauptsitz der Rockefeller Enterprises Gerechtigkeit. Rockefeller jr. muss sich vor einem Untersuchungsausschuss erklären. Gefahr droht ihm nicht, er ist ein Rockefeller. Aber der Patriarch, der nicht begreifen kann, dass diese Art von Massakren in Amerika nicht mehr hingenommen wird, ist außer sich vor Wut, dass man es wagt, seinen Sohn anzugreifen. Er erklärt öffentlich, dass er nichts Falsches daran findet, auf Gewerkschafter zu schießen und zieht damit den einhelligen Zorn der Presse auf sich. Rockefeller ist zutiefst verwundert und gibt noch mehr Geld für philanthropische Zwecke aus, um von der Affäre abzulenken.
Zu den philanthropischen Zwecken kommen wir gleich.
Beharrlichkeit.
Einfach immer weitermachen.
Wenn man dann so beharrlich war, dass da irgendwie 30 Tote rumliegen und so, kommt die nächste wichtige Tugend, die man laut Hoss und Hopf verinnerlichen soll.
Kommen wir zu Punkt Nummer 13. Einzig durch die Fähigkeit, das zu ertragen, was andere nicht auszuhalten im Stande sind, kann man das schaffen, was andere nicht schaffen. Ich denke, das ist definitiv ein ganz, ganz wichtiger Punkt. Man sagt ja auch walk in my shoes, also laufe du mal in meine Schuhe. Weil Leute treffen gerne mal eine Urteil. Leute sehen auch immer erst den Erfolg. Die sehen quasi, da hat einer jetzt ein tolles Auto oder hat ein tolles Leben oder fliegt im Privatjet oder oder oder. Sie sehen also diese Sinnbilder des Materialismus und des Erfolges, das was direkt mit Erfolg in Zusammenhang gebracht wird. Aber sie sehen nicht, dass diese Menschen oft in der Lage sind, Dinge auszuhalten, die die Masse der Menschen nicht aushalten will.
Ja, habt ihr schon Jens Spahn bei Markus Lanz gesehen? Der hält ja auch alles aus. Der hat das verinnerlicht.
Da kommt der zweitreichste Mann und sagt, du als reichster Mann kämpfst gegen die Ärmsten der Welt und auf dein Konto gehen 100.000 Tote.
Musst halt aushalten.
Das ist die Tugend, die da zählt. So, die politische Dimension auch wahnsinnig interessant. Bitte immer große Ziele und zusammenarbeiten.
Steckt dir keine kleinen Ziele, darin liegt keine Inspiration für die Seele. Wenn du inspiriert werden möchtest, dich selbst inspirieren oder dich von jemand anderen inspirieren lassen, dann ist das nicht, weil diese andere Person kleine Ziele hat. Wenn Leute sagen, wir sind von Hoss & Hopf inspiriert, dann nicht, weil wir sagen, ja, ich möchte im nächsten Jahr einen halben Kilo abgenommen haben. Ich möchte im nächsten Jahr 5000 Euro mehr Vermögen haben. Darum geht es nicht. Wir stecken uns große Ziele, große Projekte, an denen wir uns auch selbst inspirieren können. Die Seele, da muss ein Feuer drin brennen. Und dieses Feuer kann nur wirklich brennen, wenn viel Energie reinkommt. Und wenn du möchtest, dass viel Energie in dieses Feuer reinkommt, dann musst du dir ein hohes Ziel stecken, vor dem du vielleicht selber erstaunt bist, vielleicht auch selbst teilweise auch zweifelst. Ja, ich streite nicht ab, dass ich bei meinen Zielen, die ich mir setze, manchmal denke, Junge, Junge, wie soll denn wir das packen? Nur um danach wieder zu erkennen, Alter, zu krass, ich habe es wieder geschafft, weil ich mir dieses große Ziel gesetzt habe und natürlich dann auch mit Energie da rangegangen bin.
Nicht nur das, kleine Ziele machen dich zu einem Einzelkämpfer, während große Ziele dich dazu zwingen, in Teams zu denken oder sogar Unterstützer für deine Ziele zu finden. Und sie aktivieren ein ganz anderes Mindset. Man denkt plötzlich eher in Systemen, die skalierbar sind für dein Ziel, weil es viel größer ist als irgendwie einzelne Aktion. Beispiel.
Ja, jetzt kommt ein Beispiel, oder?
Also es kommen so viele Beispiele, die können wir hier weglassen, weil die das auch so spontan hin. Aber die Lebensregel von Rockefeller ist, steck dir so große Ziele, dass du dich in Lagern zusammenrotten musst, so miljöartig. Auch das ist historisch eindeutig und sehr gut belegt. Das hat ganz hervorragend geklappt.
Ob Demokraten oder Republikaner. Seine Mitglieder blockieren jede Gesetzgebung, die ihren Interessen zuvielerläuft. Ein Paradies für Reiche ist entstanden, in dem es keine Einkommens-, Unternehmens- oder Erbschaftssteuer gibt. Kein Arbeitsrecht, kein Streikrecht und keine Bankenaufsicht. Ein Paradies, das vom ununterbrochenen Zustrom neuer Migranten profitiert, die nichts mitbringen, außer ihrer Arbeitskraft. Angezogen von den beiden großen Versprechungen des amerikanischen Traums. Freiheit und Wohlstand.
Ja, wenn die alle auch mal das Buch gelesen hätten, die Briefe an den Sohlen, dann ist es auch schon gleich besser.
Ja, also große Ziele, es ist sozusagen dieses, wir machen jetzt ein Monopol, aber nicht in irgendeinem Markt, sondern in der Politik. Wir besetzen einfach den Kongress. Dann haben wir uns da abgeschottet. Das geht nur, indem wir zusammenarbeiten. Also ist klar, okay, wir machen das jetzt. Bei Rockefeller gibt es also einen großen Sinn, der ihn angetrieben hat, der Lebenssinn. In dem Fall jetzt zuerst die Rockefeller-Demo und danach Hopf zu diesem Thema. Also historisch, was war jetzt der Sinn des Ganzen? Also da in Cleveland irgendwie jede Ölreferenerie aufzukaufen, dann die Eisenbahn so zu übernehmen, dass man so einen Transportvorteil hat, dann 90 Prozent des Ganzen Öls, des Ganzen Ölhandels in Amerika zu monopolisieren und dann wird plötzlich das Auto erfunden und dann geht es erst richtig los mit dem Wohlstand. Ich sehe hier quasi nur Gier. Also es scheint keinen anderen Lebenssinn bei Rockefeller selbst zu geben als die Gier.
In Cleveland gab es damals um 1870 rund 30 Raffinerien. Eine lästige Konkurrenz, die Rockefeller ausschalten will. Er trifft eine diskrete Vereinbarung mit der Eisenbahngesellschaft, die das Öl von Cleveland in die großen Städte des Nordens transportiert. Da das Öl von Standard Oil nun günstiger befördert wird als das seiner Konkurrenten, kann Rockefeller deren Preise unterbieten. Nach zwei Jahren hat Standard Oil alle anderen Raffinerien in Cleveland aufgekauft oder aus dem Markt gedrängt. Bis das Unternehmen zu einem Koloss geworden ist, der 90 Prozent des amerikanischen Öls kontrolliert. Eine Monopolstellung, die es Rockefeller ermöglicht, die Preise in die Höhe zu treiben.
Von Karl Marx gibt es ja den Satz, je ein Kapitalist schlägt viele tot. Das ist hier genau zu beobachten. Und das Interessante ist ja immer, wenn wir da jetzt so einen arbeiteten Teams zusammen kooperiert, dann quasi, dass ja dann doch mal kurz diese Vorstellung kommt einer kooperativen Gesellschaft, was aber dann in dem Moment ja verdrängt wird von Hoss & Hopf, ist, dass nur dieses erbitterte Konkurrenzgebaren ist ja überhaupt ermöglicht, im Kapitalismus erfolgreich zu sein in dieser Art und Weise. Bedeutet also, dass genau dieser Egoismus, der dann aber mit Team gekoppelt wird, ja wirklich nur so eine ganz instrumentelle Idee des Zusammenarbeitens ist. Und dass sie dann selber quasi die Nächsten sein könnten, die totgeschlagen werden, das wird ja auch immer dann so ausgeblendet. Genau. Also der Erfolg von Hoss & Hopf und der ganzen Kryptogramm und so ist ja, ist ja das noch mal auf die Spitze getrieben und sagen wir, in einem etwas kleineren Rahmen als das, was Rockefeller dann hatte.
Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall ein Spiel ohne Maßstäbe. Hier gibt es einfach nur den Reichsten. Und der Reiche muss dann gegen sich selber spielen und heute mehr als gestern verdienen oder irgendwie so. Nun steckt darüber hinaus, über die großen Lebensziele, nichts in diesen Briefen. Also der hat jetzt nicht seinem Sohn aufgeschrieben und so weiter, sondern es ging wirklich nur Spiel das Spiel, das sind die Regeln, so wirst du super reich, so erhältst du dir ein Reichtum. Und jetzt müssen sich Hoss & Hopfs selber Gedanken dazu machen, was jetzt eigentlich ihr Lebenssinn ist. Wir hören jetzt, wie ihm das gelingt. Wir lassen Hoss noch so ein bisschen ausklingen, da war jetzt nichts Sinnvolles dabei und dann gibt Hops uns eine Antwort.
Dass das Sinn wäre, ist es aber nicht. Es ist ein komplexes Ding. Was ist dein Sinn, Philipp?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Was ist mein Sinn?
Also, für mich ist es zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt dran denke, ich habe das ja schon mal gesagt, warum arbeite ich so viel? Warum möchte ich gerne viel Geld haben? Erstens, Freiheit ist mir ganz, ganz wichtig. Ich habe so ein inneres, tiefes Gefühl. Ich muss Freiheit haben und Freiheit bedeutet für mich, ich kann hier weggehen, ich kann das aufgeben, ich kann was anderes machen. Ich kann meine Mama, meine Frau und mein Sohn immer einpacken und wir gehen nach X irgendwo hin und leben dort. Dazu muss ich die Freiheit haben, die monetäre Freiheit, um das tun zu können. Das ist der eine Punkt. Und dann ist es für mich auch, Kian, du hast es ja auch mal erzählt bei deinen Eltern, für mich ist das immer eine sehr, sehr, was mich sehr stolz macht, ist meiner Mutter, die mein Bruder und mich aufgezogen hat, meine Mutter ist alleinerziehend gewesen, der Dinge zu ermöglichen heute, dass sie stolz sein kann auf ihre Söhne, das hat mich sehr, sehr angetrieben.
So, die Definition, ja genau, das ist wahnsinnig rührend, wir lösen das jetzt mal auf. Also sein Lebenssinn besteht darin, frei zu sein. Und seine Definition von Freiheit ist, ich kann flüchten, wohin ich will.
Ich bin der Ulti, der hier flüchtling.
Also wirklich sehr gut. Die Podcast ist einfach wahnsinnig klug.
Aber das ist so toll, dass sie sich überhaupt nicht dann doch über sich selbst im Klaren sind. Also wir haben das ja in dieser Serie die KUM-Ex-Affäre gesehen, dass da am Ende der, der das ursprünglich alles eingefädelt hat und eigentlich die die die Strücken gezogen hat, ja dann von der Staatsanwältin gefragt wird, ja aber ich bin aus ihnen nicht schlau geworden und sie sind ja aus sich auch gar nicht schlau geworden. Warum haben sie das eigentlich alles gemacht? Und er kann es auch nicht beantworten. Geld kann es nicht gewesen sein, würde auch sagen Unabhängigkeit oder sonst was, aber diese Positionen sind ja relativ schnell erreicht. Naja, ich meine, wie viel, wie viel Pelzmantel kann die Mutter brauchen?
Also er gibt ja eine Antwort in dieser Serie, in der man nämlich dieser Zollbeamtin sagt, es gibt zwei Arten von Glück im Leben. Er hatte irgendeine Nonne getroffen, die gar nichts hat und die hat er als wahnsinnig glücklich empfunden. Und er wusste, das ist das Spektrum, aber ich werde auf der anderen Seite glücklich. Also einfach so viel Geld wie geht. Maßstabslos. So, ein Clip noch dazu, denn das ist historisch ganz interessant, diese Philanthropie. Wir haben jetzt schon gehört, das ist aus einer Zeit, in der es quasi gar keine Menschenrechte gab und auch keine irgendwelche steuerlichen Belastungen oder irgendwas. Es war wirklich wilder Westen. Bis Woodrow Wilson kam, der dann meinte, nee, das macht irgendwie keinen Sinn, wenn die Fed, wenn die GP. Morgan Bank damals den Dollar betreut, sondern wir bräuchten mal so eine Zentralbank oder wir bräuchten eigentlich mal so einen Nachwuchs. Wir machen jetzt mal Kinderarbeitsverbot und lauter solche Sachen. Unter anderem auch von ihm Einkommenssteuer. Und jetzt hören wir, wo die Philanthropie von, von, ne, Philanthropie heißt es, ne? Fi, nicht Pi, ja, Philanthropie. Wo die herkommt bei Rockefeller.
Und schließlich, Philanthropie.
Philanthropie, okay, gut.
Und schließlich müssen die reichsten vier Prozent der Amerikaner nun eine Einkommenssteuer zahlen. Mit einem Spitzensatz von anfänglich sieben Prozent. Das zieht ausdrücklich auf die großen Vermögen ab. Allen voran auf das Rockefellers. Doch der Milliardär findet prompt einen Weg, um der Steuer zu entgehen.
Der Senat hat das Gesetz verabschiedet, das Rockefellers Philanthropie anerkennt. Die Rockefeller-Stiftung ist damit in der Lage, Gelder zu erhalten und über sie zu verfügen, um, Zitat, das Wohlergehen der Menschheit weltweit zu fördern. New York Times, 15. April 1913. Beschuldigungen gegen Rockefeller und Carnegie-Stiftungen. New York Times, 6. Mai 1930 John D.
Rockefeller und Andrew Carnegie nutzen ihren Einfluss im Kongress, um zu erreichen, dass der philantropiegewidmete Mittel von der Einkommenssteuer befreit werden. Und sie setzen sich durch.
7% Einkommenssteuer. Also, wer irgendwelche Briefe liest, weil Rockefeller seinem Sohn irgendwelche Weisheiten mitgegeben hat, das ist alles geschichtsvergessene Idiotie. Das ist wirklich grandios. Aber das ist, wir kennen ja jetzt den Namen, das ist Synchrotismus in der Luhnerei noch voraus.
Und das Schlimme ist ja jetzt, das ist ja kein Geheimwissen, sondern das ist Arte, das steht auch bei YouTube. Also, es steht quasi neben Hoss & Hopf. Und das Hoss & Hopf-Publikum sieht das aber nicht. Das, was da steht, also, die könnten das, was wir jetzt hier gerade besprochen haben, ja, eins zu eins so nachvollziehen. Also, diese Verbindung herzustellen, die einen Klick entfernt.
Ja, aber der wird nicht gemacht.
Und das ist das Faszinierende, dass das Wissen darüber absolut verfügbar ist und dass man alles, was Hoss & Hopf sagt, in dem Moment widerlegen kann. Und genau das findet nicht statt. Also, es sind ja andere Zeiten, als die, in denen tatsächlich man denen wohl glauben musste, wenn die das im Fernsehen oder so gesagt haben, wo soll man es auch sonst ja wissen. Aber hier ist es tatsächlich die Selbstbeschränkung des eigenen Geistes, die den Erfolg von Hoss & Hopf so groß macht.
Ja, es ist sehr betrüblich, dass Leute diesen Podcast so intensiv hören und dann dieses Ticket für 70 Euro kaufen, um sich darüber belehren zu lassen, dass sie bloß keinen Flur in ihrer Zahnpaste haben sollen.
Wir kommen jetzt zur AfD und zu Maximilian Krah. Der war in Schnellroder zu Gast bei Ellen Kursitsa und Götz Kubitschek. Denn diese beiden, Kubitschek und Kursitsa, sind ja die Intellektuellen, die quasi der AfD-Wege aufzeigen, wie man strategisch den Rechtsdruck herbeiführen kann. Sie sind ja die Intellektuellen im Ganzen, mit denen aber Krah ja immer wieder im Austausch war. Wir haben ja auch schon mal Clips gespielt. Nun aber ist Krah quasi vorgeladen, denn es ist folgendermaßen.
Willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Am Rande der Gesellschaft.
Der knistert nur so früh so.
Wir haben ja heute als Gast den Dr. Maximilian Krah. An meiner Seite ist Götz Kubitschek und hier spricht meine Wenigkeit Ellen Kursitsa.
Ja, diese drei hören wir.
Herr Krah, wir haben viele Fragen.
Ja, deshalb bin ich da. Sie stellen die Fragen, ich gebe die Antwort und sie gehen nach Hause und sagen wunderbar, alles ist aufgeklärt.
Wärmer sehen, wärmer sehen.
Also Stimmung von Anfang an nicht gut. Überhaupt nicht gut, denn der Verleger macht sich Sorgen.
Ich als Verleger und Sie sind ja einer unserer Autoren, ich als Verleger beunruhigt bin über die Diskussionen und Turbulenzen, die es nicht nur im Netz, sondern auch in vielen Gesprächen, die ich führte, gab, um Aussagen, Positionen von Ihnen, Richtungsänderungen, die wahrnehmbar sind, also mehr als wahrnehmbar.
Ja, was ist da gemeint? Das rumort also kräftig. Der Begriff Remigration ist ja durch die Korrektiv-Recherchen so richtig dann in der breiten Öffentlichkeit diskutiert worden. Die Proteste auf den Straßen, wir erinnern uns. Davor wurde dieser Begriff natürlich in Schnellroder geprägt, durch Sellner, Krah aber auch und einige andere. Und nun ist ja die große Gefahr, dass dieser Begriff möglicherweise von Krah gar nicht mehr so gemeint ist. Also diese Gefahr sehen zumindest die Kubitscheks. So. Und deswegen muss ich Krah da mal zu äußern. Wir fangen erst mal mit Krah an, der so sagt, wir sind katastrophalen Zeiten.
Die Einwanderung schreitet massiv voran, das ist das eine. Wir sehen immer mehr, in was für eine demografische Katastrophe wir hereingehen. Die Fertilitätsrate wird bis Ende des Jahrzehnts auf eins gehen. Das heißt, wir halbieren uns.
Große demografische Frage, nicht im Sinne von, wer zahlt die Rente, sondern wirklich Volkstod. Das ist ja das Thema. Wir haben das ja jetzt auch schon in anderen Podcasts gehört, dass offenbar die Gebärfähigkeit von Frauen gewährleistet werden muss und so von angeblich progressiven Journalistinnen vorgetragen im Deutschlandfunk. Aber hier ist natürlich so eine ethnische Kategorie gleich dabei. Man kann es nicht denken. Und es geht jetzt also um diesen Begriff der Remigration.
Meine Befürchtung ist, dass wir uns zurückziehen auf das eine Thema, gar nicht mal der Einwanderungsbegrenzung, sondern eben der Rückführung der Remigration. Und dass dieses eine Thema einen zu großen Rahmen einnimmt und dass quasi das jetzt zur alleinigen Gretchenfrage gemacht wird, ob man orthodox rechts ist oder nicht orthodox rechts ist.
Was ist also hier los?
Also wir sehen ja, wie weit es in Amerika getrieben wird. Aber das hätte ja keiner gedacht, dass Leute, die noch ihr Hispanics for Trump 2024-T-Shirt anhaben, schon in Handschellen abgeführt werden. In der Hinsicht vielleicht zu Recht so eine Diskussion.
Ja, genau. Obwohl jetzt sich Krah nachher von Trump absetzen wird. Also er sagt ja, der Krah, der hat da sowieso, der Trump hat da nochmal so eine liberalere Auffassung eigentlich. Also wenn wir jetzt hier von Liberaler sprechen in diesem Zusammenhang, dann sollte immer klar sein, zu extrem rechten Positionen, da gibt es auch immer Schattierungen. Also nicht, dass am Ende jemand sagt, ja, ach dann sind da auch ganz Liberale dabei oder so. Das natürlich nicht. Ellen Kursitsa jedenfalls ist fassungslos darüber, dass Krah überhaupt korrektiv Auskunft gegeben hat.
Warum das Rückrudern in einer, in einem Medium wie korrektiv, wo sie exklusiv haben, verkünden sich, haben zitieren lassen mit den Worten, ich habe nachgedacht im Rahmen der Protestwelle aufgrund der korrektiv Berichterstattung habe ich neu nachgedacht über das Prinzip der Multiethnizität und sie sehen jetzt einiges sehr anders. Das war eine Sache, die bis heute jeden aus unserem Lager eigentlich vor den Kopf geschlossen hat.
Das erstaunt mich, dass das so ist, weil so, also der Vorwurf ist hier ganz deutlich, Krah passt sich an den journalistischen Mainstreamer an.
Aber ist das die Wehrpflichtsdebatte auf der linken Seite? Du würdest jetzt nicht schießen, oder was?
Jan, noch erbitterter und fundamentaler, würde ich sagen. Wir hören mal weiter.
Genauso hat man versucht, den Begriff Volk unmöglich zu machen. Das ist auch nicht gelungen. Das liegt daran, dass eben unter anderem die AfD hartnäckig darauf beharrt hat, dass es ein Volk gibt. Darauf beharr ich auch. Und dass das natürlich etwas mit Ethnos, also mit Abstammung zu tun hat. Und dass man sich diesen Abstammungsbegriff auch nicht vom Brot nehmen lässt.
Moment, da verstehen Sie mich ja falsch, aber darüber schreite ich gar nicht.
Ja, aber immer kam dieses Zeug als Boomerang zurück.
Es geht um die Frage, ob es ein Ethnos oder nicht. Der Verfassungsschutz behauptet, es gibt nicht mal ein Ethnos.
Der Verfassungsschutzbericht ist für die Herrschaften übrigens gar kein großes Thema. Da würden Leute schreiben, die keine Ahnung haben. Und das ist für sie nicht interessant. Bei den Gerichten sieht es nachher schon anders aus, wie wir merken werden. Jetzt aber erst mal zu Trumps Remigration. Denn dieser Begriff ist ja tatsächlich global immer wieder im Munde geführt.
Remigration, wie ihn Trump verwendet und so weiter, bedeutet doch, dass man im großen Stil Leute aus der Landesschaft, die da nichts zu suchen haben, also die nicht Staatsbürger sind, die kriminell geworden sind. Die man aufgrund einer Staatsbürgerschaft oder einer strafrechtlichen Verurteilung wieder aus der Landesschaft. Das, was in Deutschland passiert und was die Linken tun und was die Behörden tun, ist, dass sie sagen, die AfD oder das Vorfeld meint aber mit Remigration nicht, dass die nicht Staatsbürger und Kriminellen rausgeschafft werden, sondern sie meint, dass die Staatsbürger unterschieden werden nach ihrer Volkszugehörigkeit.
Also die Remigration, so lautet der Vorwurf, sagt er von links, ist bei den Rechten nicht nur die Ausweisung von Menschen mit Asylstatus oder so, sondern geht auch an die, die schon eine Staatsbürgerschaft haben. Und wir können hier ohne jetzt direkt Vergleiches machen, aber doch gewisse Parallelen sehen. Wir hatten ja im Januar eine Debatte darüber, ob die, die eine doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft haben, diese entzogen bekommen können, wenn sie sich beispielsweise antisemitisch äußern. Das war ja etwas, was Span und März ins Spiel gebracht haben. Also sind sie eigentlich da krasser unterwegs gewesen als Krah? Denn Krah, so werden wir jetzt gleich merken, wird immer wieder sagen, also dann diese Leute, die eine Staatsbürgerschaft haben, da können wir so nicht ran. Das ist ganz interessant, dass Krah hier so einen Weg macht. Und wir müssen jetzt das unter verschiedenen Gesichtspunkten sehen. Also einmal natürlich die Frage nach Volk, Ethnizität, Staatsvolk und so. Das müssen wir jetzt klären, was die da meinen und aber auch sehen. In gewisser Weise ist natürlich der Schnellroder-Vorwurf richtig, dass wir hier eine Normalisierung der AfD erleben. Also die AfD versucht, sich zu normalisieren. Man könnte auch sagen, zu zähmen. Natürlich mit der großen Gefahr, die dann für uns darin besteht, dass dann also zum Beispiel gerichtliche Handhabe über die AfD schwierig wird, wenn diese Normalisierung stattfindet. Und ja, vieles deutet darauf hin. Also wenn die AfD quasi ungefährlicher wird, wird sie gleichzeitig auch gefährlicher.
Ja, also so wie ich das jetzt bisher hier hinhöre, ist das ja, du sagst, da spielt der Verfassungsschutzbericht jetzt nicht so die große Rolle, aber der schwingt ja die ganze Zeit mit, weil der Verfassungsschutzbericht sagt ja...
Und das UVG-Urteil aus Münster.
Genau, also ihr dürft relativ viel freie Meinungsäußerung mäßig machen, außer bei der Staatsbürgerschaft binndifferenzieren. Und klar geht ja voll darauf ein.
Ja, weiter.
Und dass wir in Wahrheit unter Remigration ein ethnisches Programm verstehen. Das ist ja das, was uns vorgehalten wird. Der Trump versteht unter Remigration kein ethnisches Programm, sondern er versteht ein juristisches Programm darunter. Das selbe gilt auch für Simur in Frankreich. Auch dem geht es nicht um ein ethnisches Programm. Logischerweise ist er selbst, er hat algerische Wurzeln.
Ja, also das wird Krah noch auf die Füße fallen, das so zu sehen, weil wir sehen ja bei Trump, dass das eben kein juristisches Programm ist, sondern die werden losgeschickt. Wenn jemand so aussieht wie, nehmt ihn erstmal mit und dann kommt er erst gar nicht zu einem Verfahren.
Aber wenn sie eine Staatsbürgerschaft haben, können sie natürlich nicht ausgewiesen werden in den USA.
Ja, genau. Aber dann haben wir diesen Sonderfall, dass wir diese Zwischenphase haben, dass man in Kalifornien relativ viele relativ frei duldet, weil hier sind ja alle Wahlämter von Demokraten besetzt und die schieben euch nicht ab. Und dann plötzlich wird das als juristische Keule missbraucht, dass man ja auch einfach anders im Alltag das Handhaben könnte. Aber während die die Leute einsammeln, die zeigen ja weder ihre Warrants, ihre Gesuche, noch lassen die sich einen Ausweis zeigen, sondern da ist man erstmal weg.
Nur geht es ja nicht um Amerikaner, die die Staatsbürgerschaft haben.
Da wird es dann heikel. Das kommt ja jetzt in den nächsten Tagen dann, wenn diese Verfahren mal...
Niemand lässt das ernsthaft offen, wenn er aus unseren Reihen über Remigration spricht.
Wissen Sie, dass ich für den Post sagte, Remigration muss klar definiert sein. Und das darf nicht so klingen, als sei es hier um ein ethnisches, sondern es gehe um ein rechtliches Programm. Was ich dafür in Schitztum gekriegt habe.
Weil Sie ganz komisch rechtspositivistisch argumentiert haben. Staatsbürgerschaft ist rechtspositivistisch. Nein, das hat alles was mit Macht zu tun. Rechtspositivismus würde bedeuten, dass all das, was Merkel ab 2015 erlaubt hat, natürlich vollkommen widerrechtlich war.
Leider nicht wahr.
Und wie der Kubitschek da rangeht, wird man sofort verboten. Dann würde jeder im Bundestag sagen, wir müssen den Antrag jetzt stellen.
Genau.
Das ist ja völlig absurd.
Und Krah kann das natürlich nicht so ganz ausdrücklich sagen. Kubitschek muss sich auch noch ein bisschen so zurückhalten, weil natürlich sonst da ein Schneller Roder ganz schnell Schluss ist. Aber was auch lustig ist, dass Kubitschek den Rechtspositivismus nicht versteht. Also Rechtspositivismus meint hier tatsächlich, dass da das Recht gesetzt wird und das gilt dann. Und wenn Merkel sagt, ich öffne die Grenzen und mache Leute zu Staatsbürgern, die vorher noch Syrer waren, dann ist das rechtspositivistisch argumentiert. Und dann kann man das eben nicht, wie Kubitschek meint, als ein Unrecht oder so bezeichnen. Und das hat Krah, der ja Jurist ist, verstanden. Aber Kubitschek kommt da einfach nicht weiter erstmal und versucht jetzt, das mit dem Volk und so immer besser zu argumentieren. Es wird aber immer schwieriger eigentlich für ihn. Es geht jetzt um die Russlanddeutschen.
Im Grundgesetz steht und weil es natürlich eine Abstammungsdefinition gibt, die bis heute Nachfahren Russlanddeutscher oder Rumäniendeutscher und so weiter erlaubt, diese ist sofort einzuwandern und sofort sozusagen die Staatsbürgerschaft zu bekommen und diesem Volk weiterhin anzugehören. Oder diesem Staatsbürgerschaft. Und das ist leider unpräzise.
Das ist das Problem. Und diese Unpräzision, die wir hier haben, kostet uns, wenn wir Pech haben, richtig Blut.
Es ist hochinteressant, ne? Also, was Krah hier sagt, es gibt ein Staatsvolk. Der ist aber jetzt noch nicht damit beim deutschen Volk angelangt. Der ist bei einem Staatsvolk. Also, die Leute, die eine Staatsbürgerschaft haben, sind ein Staatsvolk. Das ist die Idee von Krah. Kubitschek will das aber nicht. Dann geht es mal kurz um das Interview, das Krah Tilo Jung gegeben hat.
Der Tilo Jung hat mir erklärt, es gäbe überhaupt keine ethnischen Völker. Das sei alles verfassungswidrig. Und habe ich ihm gesagt, dann guck mal bitte ins Grundgesetz, da steht auch drin, es gibt deutsche Volkszugehörige. Was ist denn das? Da war er Schachmatt. Daran rüttel ich doch nicht. Es gibt ein deutsches Volk, das ist eine Kultur- und Abstammungsgemeinschaft.
Aber das ist nicht unbedingt das Staatsvolk. Krah sagt dann weiter.
Alles, was ich tue und was ich im Übrigen für alternativlos halte, weil es sonst a. nicht mehr mit der Realität im Land übereinstimmt, das ist leider so, und weil wir auch massiven Ärger kriegen werden, ist, dass ich sage, lernen zu unterscheiden zwischen dem deutschen Volk und der Gemeinschaft der Deutschen Passte.
Also der Deutschen Mitte Passte.
Aber da bringt er sich ja selber auch schon wieder an die Bredouille.
Naja, vielleicht ja nicht. Jetzt kommt nämlich Kubitschek und versucht aber doch nochmal, das mit dem Staat zu rechtfertigen. Und eigentlich ist das jetzt eine Argumentation, die Kubitschek eher zu einem liberalen Macht, also liberalen Anführungszeichen.
Das tut jeder von uns.
Nein, das tut niemand, weil man es immer zurückkoppelt.
Das tut jeder von uns und das können Sie alles nachlesen. Was ich lese, ist teilweise falsch. Dass wir natürlich mit diesen schlimmen, schlimmen Fehlern, die unsere jetzige Regierung seit Jahrzehnten macht und die eben auch unsere Vorläufergeneration und Teile unserer jetzigen Generation macht, dass wir leider Gottes leben müssen. Dass die unsere Staatsbürgerschaft verschärbelt wie sauer Bier. Dass jeder diesen Zettel oder diesen Pass in die Hand bekommt, der sich weder zu diesem Volk und zu dieser Schicksalsgemeinschaft bekennt, diesen Lappen eben mittlerweile nach ein paar Jahren von ihm bekommt.
Ist das noch nicht die große Frage, die sich interessiert, warum soll jetzt...
Das klingt ja so wahnsinnig rechts, sich zur Schicksalsgemeinschaft bekennen. Und in gewisser Weise ist es das natürlich. Aber das ist auch ein Diskurs, den man im bürgerlichen, auch bis in linksliberales Lager hinein hat, nämlich dann, wenn man zum Beispiel sagt, dass die, die Migrationshintergrund haben und bereit sind, in der Bundeswehr zu dienen, schneller an eine Staatsbürgerschaft kommen sollen. Oder wenn man sagt, dass sich die, die muslimisch sind, noch mal in besonderer Weise vom Antisemitismus abgrenzen sollen, um weiterhin die Toleranz der Gesellschaft zu erleben. Eine Aussage, die Habeck damals in seinem Video zu Antisemitismus in Deutschland getroffen hat. Also was hier von Kubitschek eingefordert ist, ist zu sagen, du musst dich ganz und gar bekennen. Das bedeutet aber, und er würde natürlich sagen, und ganz viele können das gar nicht, weil die kulturfern sind, das ist dann immer sein Wort. Also die Polen könnten das hier oder die Franzosen, wenn sie in Deutschland leben, aber andere dann nun nicht. Aber man sieht, also das ist ja eine Frage von Bekenntnis. Das ist ja wie, ich kann jetzt katholisch werden oder so, egal woher ich komme, lasse mich taufen, bin ich katholisch. Und da hat Krah ein Problem. Also wir könnten jetzt auch uns die Frage stellen, wer ist eigentlich der Rechtere von den beiden? Man könnte jetzt sagen, also du hast schon zurecht gesagt, naja, der Kubitschek kommt in Teufelsküche damit. Aber in gewisser Weise ist der Krah rechter, weil der wirklich völkisch stinkt.
Wer jetzt hierherkommt als, sagen wir mal, nehmen wir ruhig den Syrer und der bekommt einen deutschen Pass, wozu muss der sich denn bekennen? Bekennt er sich zu dem Rechtskonstrukt Bundesrepublik Deutschland? Oder muss er sich bekennen, der Schicksalsgemeinschaft ist etnisch deutsch?
Also er tut ja weder noch. Und wissen Sie, in Ländern, in denen es ein bisschen strenger abläuft, da dauert es 20 Jahre, bis sie so ein Ding bekommen.
Wozu muss er sich bekennen?
Das ist ja wahnsinnig kompliziert. Ich habe immer gehört, die rechte Seite fängt ihre Wähler über einfache Antworten, mit dem Flow gehen und so weiter. Jetzt muss man hier plötzlich so mit dem Skype-Held, so eine Diskussion.
Ja, wir sind jetzt hier in Schneiroda. Hier ist ja das große rechte Denken. Kubitschek versucht, das jetzt zu erklären. Und naja, kann ja mal jeder beurteilen, ob das so ihm gelingt.
Er muss, er muss sich dazu bekennen, dass er, also ich habe das mal so formuliert, er muss auf Gedei und Verderb die Sache dieses Volkes zu seiner Sache machen. Das heißt also, des Staatsvolkes oder des ethnischen Volkes? Also dieses historisch hergekommenen Volkes, also das immer ein ethnisches Volk plus, nein, plus, plus dazugekommen.
Also wenn die das so abfeiern, dann hat man doch ein Beispiel dafür, wie das zumindest in einem überschaubaren familiären Bereich überall außerhalb Europas als Anschauungsmaterial dafür. Wir kriegen es ja nicht mal hin, Familien zusammenzuhalten. Da ist ja lauter Streit, nur weil mal irgendwie eine Hausfeier abführt oder so. Und er will jetzt die große deutsch-völkische Schicksalsgemeinschaft, die sich...
Ja und Kubitschek öffnet das ja hier für andere. Also das will Krah werden wir gleich hören nicht, sondern er öffnet das auf Gedeihung und Verderb. Das sind zwar harte Worte, aber das ist ja generell erstmal möglich, also dass man das werden kann. Während, wenn ich jetzt sage, nee, das ethnische Volk ist das ethnische Volk, und da kann ich mich noch so sehr anstrengen und irgendwelche Bekenntnisse abgeben oder so, ich gehöre niemand dazu, dann ist das dann etwas anderes. Man könnte erst mal sagen, ja, aber dann ist ja doch der Krah, der eigentlich die Gefährdlichere. Wir hören mal weiter, weil ja jetzt so Kubitschek so sagt, ja, die kommen und das würde ja sonst, also die müssten das dann auf Gedeihung und Verderb tun.
Und jetzt gibt es, es gibt jetzt welche, die dazugekommen sind oder dazukommen.
Wo kommen die dazu?
So, die stoßen zu diesem Volk.
Kommen sie zum Staatsvolk oder zum Äthnischen Volk dazu?
Das ist die interessante Frage. Also die sind sich, also man muss sich das auch mal so vorstellen. Die machen, also die Kubitscheks machen seit 25, über 25 Jahren rechten Aktivismus. Der Krah macht jetzt seit über 10 Jahren AfD. Und die klären jetzt erst mal für sich. Wen meinen wir eigentlich, wenn wir vom deutschen Volk reden? Möglicherweise, wie sich jetzt nachher herausstellen wird, haben die immer unterschiedliche Leute adressiert.
Vor allem, die stellen diese Frage so in den Raum, als ob nicht auf tausend Seiten die Frage ausgearbeitet wurde, mit dem Hinweis, also wenn ihr dazu kommt, das zu unterscheiden, verbieten wir euch sofort. Wieso fühle ich das so in der Öffentlichkeit?
Ja toll, ne?
Also wenn das jetzt so ein Küchengespräch wäre, dass so, ja, da hat jemand ein Mikro mitlaufen lassen, und dann würde man das hören, wäre das voll skandalös.
Ja, ja, also nicht, dass wir jetzt in einem halben Jahr wieder eine Korrektivrecherche bekommen. Also hier ist es ganz ausdrücklich gesagt. Jetzt hat Kubitschek in die Ecke gedrängt, noch so eine Idee, Kulturnähe.
Also sie kommen natürlich zum Staatsvolk dazu. Ja, so. Aber wichtig ist, und das ist eben der Punkt, wenn sie dazu stoßen, dass sie sich assimilieren. Und jetzt ist die große Frage, ob wir das wollen, ob das überhaupt möglich ist, ob wir unterscheiden zwischen Kulturferne und Kulturnähe, ob wir unterscheiden zwischen Masse oder Wenigen.
Wie wäre es denn, wenn wir unterscheiden zwischen Volk und Nichtvolk?
So, nämlich was Kubitschek hier sagt, also jetzt überspitzt ausgedrückt, ist etwas, das findet man in fast allen Parteien, die wir im Bundestag sitzen, haben. Die sprechen dann nicht von Assimilation, die sagen Integration. Aber man muss sich schon ein bisschen anpassen und so würde fast jeder da so sagen. Also da könnte man jetzt, Jens Spahn formuliert das auf seine Art, Jermöztemi auf eine andere. Aber im Prinzip überführt jetzt Krah, Kubitschek, dass er eigentlich diesem liberalen Lage angehört, also dass es offenbar doch ein Bekenntnis so gibt. Jetzt wird Kubitschek immer wieder sagen, es sind aber zu viele und die sind kulturfern und so weiter. Aber grundsätzlich hält er das also für möglich. Und Krah hört jetzt diesen Begriff Assimilation. Und das ist ja ein Kampfbegriff auch aus den 20er Jahren der Neurechten da. Also der der konservativen Revolutionäre. Es gibt einen sehr berühmt berüchtigten Aufsatz, zum Beispiel von Ernst Jünger über die Judenfrage. Und da artikuliert Ernst Jünger die Furcht davor, dass Juden in Deutschland sich assimilieren, also nicht mehr als solche erkannt werden. Er ist nicht gegen Juden in Deutschland, aber dass man sie nicht mehr erkennt. Er will sie also separiert haben, sichtbar haben, sie sollen entsprechend gewandet sein und so etwas. Und das ist jetzt plötzlich natürlich bei Krah der Schlüssebegriff, dass also alles bitte noch klar unterscheidbar werden soll. Aber wenn die sich anpassen, integrieren oder wie immer man das nennen möchte, dann haben die jetzt das Problem, wir haben eben das mit der Geburtenrate schon gehört. Also es gibt ja diese große Angst bei den neuen Rechten, dass sie irgendwann wirklich nicht mehr ein Volk haben, das sie meinen. Also sie sind ja sich sowieso, wie wir merken schon, uneins. Aber ich habe hier mal im Podcast über Dating gesprochen, hier im Live-Salon und habe gesagt, eigentlich das Beste gegen rechts ist, eine maximale Vermischung herzustellen, weil die dann nicht mehr zugreifen können. Und gewissermaßen ist es genau das. Also das ist die Angst. Deswegen sagen die ja immer, dieses Jahrzehnt ist so entscheidend. Das sagt auch Selna, weil sie tatsächlich eine Angst haben, dass durch Eheschließungen etc., wir werden das gleich nochmal explizit hören, dass dadurch plötzlich sich diese Kategorie des ethnischen Volkes, die sie da meinen, in Luft auflöst.
Wenn jemand hier deutscher Staatsbürger wird, dann gliedert er sich ins Staatsvolk ein. Und jetzt sagen sie, er soll sich auch in das ethnische Volk assimilieren. Da sind sie linker von mir. Das will ich zum Beispiel nicht. Das sage ich gar nicht unbedingt. Ich halte Assimilation für ein Synonym von Melting Pot.
Also, Kubitschek hat ja eben schon die Staatsbürgerurkunde, wie auch immer, die man dann da ausgehändigt kriegt, als Lappen bezeichnet und so. Und eigentlich sagt dir der Krah, ja, genau, die kriegen einfach so einen Lappen. Während wir die feierliche Urkunde zur Geburt und so weiter. Also eigentlich könnten die sich auch einigen.
Ja, vielleicht hat Kubitschek durch seine Preußenverehrung doch am Ende ist der Staatsbegriff ihm wichtiger als der Volksbegriff. Ich glaube, das ist die Differenz hier.
Ich möchte schon, dass das deutsche ethnische Volk mit seinen kulturellen Eigenheiten bestehen bleibt.
Kositsa, die fast die ganze Zeit nichts sagt, mischt sich immer ein.
Und wenn ich aber hier hunderttausende assimiliere und mich also verschmelze, dann ist das Ding ethno-kulturell, dann öffnen sie das ethnische Volk für eine lästliche Melting-Pod.
Aber keinen Stroman aufbauen. Niemand von uns hat gesagt, dass wir hunderttausende hier assimilieren.
Aber was machen Sie denn dann mit den Staatsbürgern?
Das ist ja das, was Kubitschek als ihren Rechtspositivismus angegriffen hat. Sie sagen, das ist nun mal Recht.
Ja, dann kann er ihr nur jetzt sagen, ja, das ist nun mal Recht.
Aber Sie kennen noch, kennen Karl Orff, kennen dieses Stück, die Kluge, ja. Wer das macht hat, Ach, haben wir auch gesehen. Wer die Macht hat, hat das Recht. Und wer das Recht hat, bricht es auch.
Aber liebe Frau Kursitzer, die Gleichheit der Staatsbürger, die Gleichheit der Staatsbürger allein aufgrund dieses Zettels, den man hat, ist der Gründungsmythos des modernen Staates.
Also nun sind Sie halt nun mal da.
Das ist der Gründungsmythos des modernen Staates. Wenn Sie das vertreten, dann muss Ihnen klar sein, dass dieser moderne Staat Sie mit allem verfolgen wird, was er kann.
Wir sehen das Dilemma.
Er wird Sie mit verfolgen, mit allem, was er kann. Weil der Gründungs-, der moderne Staat basiert auf der Idee...
Also mit anderen Worten, der Krah könnte jetzt auch sagen, lieber Verfassungsschutz, wenn ihr gerade zuhört, hier in Schnellroda sind komische Leute.
D, dass es nur Staatsbürger gibt und die in einem unmittelbaren Verhältnis zum Staat sind.
Aber Sie haben doch selbst gesagt, man muss an Denken adaptieren an veränderte Begegnheiten.
Ja, das tue ich ja. Indem ich Ihnen sage, dann sagen wir doch einfach, die sind Staatsbürger, aber wir sind weiter ethnisch-deutsche. Und wir akzeptieren also, dass es unterhalb der deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft verschiedene ethnische Gruppen gibt. Und zwar mit 80% oder über 80% Deutschen, aber es gibt auch andere ethnische Gruppen. Und zwar, nehmen Sie ein Beispiel, wir haben in Sachsen die Sorbische Minderheit.
Also, möchte Krah hier so ein zweites Binnen-Deutschland etablieren?
Genau.
Dass man sagt, okay, ihr habt zwar eine Einbürgerungsurkunde bekommen, aber hier braucht ihr auch unser Geld oder sowas. Ja, also dass man sonst eine erste Klasse noch mal heraushält.
Oder hier braucht ihr nicht hin, denn hier sind wir Deutschen.
Ja, aber damit sind ja beide auf diesem vom Verfassungsschutz markierten Gelände, auf dem es brenzlig wird.
Ja, es wird gleich das Wort communities nehmen und das Wort communities kennen wir eher so aus linksprogressiven Bewegungen, aus kolonialen Bewegungen oder so. Und man kann ja zum Beispiel sagen, wir müssen was für die einzelnen communities tun, damit die auch ihre Kultur ausleben können und so weiter. Also das wäre jetzt im Prinzip klingt es ja wie linksprogressiver Ansatz. Ja, und so ist ja natürlich auch bei den linksprogressiven gemeint. Ja, aber wenn ich natürlich also, die haben auch oftmals oder einen merkwürdigen ethnischen Volksbegriff, also auch das ist natürlich ein Problem. Also das, das ist nicht so ganz ohne. Also für die, die immer in so Communities denken, die in dieser Art der Identitätspolitik sind, nicht der rechten, sondern der linken Identitätspolitik, das ist natürlich auch immer wieder eine Einladung zu sehr homogenem Denken, das dann nicht als völkisch bezeichnet wird, aber das eine gewisse Nähe dazu hat und natürlich mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbar ist.
Ich will da nicht die ganze Welt reinlassen. Ich will die Grenzen schließen.
Wir haben sie aber reingelassen und das ist ein Riesenproblem. Und das kann man aus meiner Sicht nicht rechtspositivistisch beantworten.
Doch, indem sie darauf hinwirken, dass diese Communities unter sich bleiben. Wie denn?
So und das ist jetzt gerade zum Beispiel...
Ich schaue mir gerade die Zahlen an, wo syrische Einwanderer ab 2015 sich ansiedeln. Die ziehen gerade im großen Stil in Ruhrgebietsstädte. Warum? Weil da die Mieten niedrig sind und weil es Wohnraum gibt. Das führt zu der lustigen Situation, dass es im Ruhrgebiet zurzeit Verteilungskämpfe zwischen den dort ansässigen Türken und den Syrern gibt.
Also wenn der Selektionsmechanismus billige Mieten sind, sind wir ja auf ökonomischem Gelände. Dann könnte er ja die ostdeutschen Gegenden, die ich gerne renaturalisieren würde, bereit machen für, und da gibt es übrigens billige Mieten.
Ja, könnte er machen, ja.
Rund um den Landschaftspark da von Kubitschek.
Genau, ja. Also was wir jetzt hier beruhe machten ist natürlich, der Kubitschek spielt mit dem Feuer, der ist ja aber auch ja nur Verleger und hat da so seinen kleinen Think Tank. Der andere will ja politische Macht. Das bedeutet also, wir leben jetzt hier wie die AfD, offiziell zumindest. Also man muss das natürlich auch immer wieder als Uneigentliches sprechen sehen. Wir wissen ja gar nicht, wie ehrlich es jetzt Krah in dem Zusammenhang ist. Vielleicht macht er diesen Auftritt auch, um dem Verfassungsschutz und den Gerichten zu zeigen, seht her, ich argumentiere nicht wie die Kubitscheks. Ich bin nämlich eigentlich jemand, der sagt, der Nationalstaat, der ist stark, gerade dann, wenn alle die gleichen Rechte haben und so etwas. Also das wissen wir alle nicht, welche wirkliche Strategie dahinter ist. Jedenfalls ist es auf diesem Weg eine, die AfD zu normalisieren. Bedeutet also auch eine Öffnung hin zur CDU und ist eigentlich etwas, was wir ja in Europa mehrfach schon beobachten konnten und was der Journalist Sebastian Friedrich als Melonisierung der AfD bezeichnet hat. Also dass da die AfD auf diesem Wege ist, ja, wie Meloni zu agieren, bedeutet also auch dann, koalitionsoffener zu sein, wovor die Maximalisten Kubitschek natürlich Angst haben. Jetzt fragen wir uns natürlich, wie meint er das mit diesen Communities?
Das heißt, wir müssen eher dafür sein, dass jede Gruppe erst mal ihre eigene Identität, vor allen Dingen die Deutschen, ihre eigene Identität wiederfinden. Und wir dürfen nicht zulassen, was zum Beispiel in Holland, eher in Dänemark passiert, dass man Kinder mit Bussen hin und her karrt, um die Schulen zu durchmischen.
Also er will eigentlich Segregation haben und möchte jede Art der Durchmischung, und die fängt natürlich in den Schulen an, will er unterbinden. Deswegen ist für die der Osten so ein Umkampf, das fällt auch, weil sie da ja sowieso wenige Migranten haben, wenige Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund haben. Da ist also die Abschottung viel besser. Und dass das natürlich auch dann offen ist für Rasse, Gedanken und so etwas. Ich überlege ein bisschen, ob wir in den nächsten Wochen mal über Erik Ahrens sprechen sollten oder nicht. Jedenfalls sind da natürlich Anknüpfungspunkte, die Krah hier sicherlich aus Gründen nicht ausformuliert, aber er hat ja wahrscheinlich schon mal darüber nachgedacht.
80 Prozent aller Grundschüler Ausländer, das ist doch keine kleine Gruppe mehr.
Aber die kriegen sie nicht raus.
Die kriegen sie nicht raus. Die müssen mit ihnen umgehen. Schauen Sie, Frau Kursitzer, Sie glauben immer, Sie können die einfach, Sie kriegen sie nicht raus. Sie kriegen sie nicht raus.
Aber Sie haben es doch so schön erklärt bereits 2024 in Videos, wie man durch Anreizsysteme erzählt, aber trotzdem bleibt eine relativ große Zahl übrig.
Ja, denn in dem Buch von Martin Sellner ist ja, dass schon fünf, sechs Jahre alt ist, gibt es ja so eine Utopie am Ende, also für uns alle eine Dystopie, aber für ihn eine Utopie, wie Österreich wieder aussehen kann. Dann sind da die Ethnisch-Österreicher, die wieder Volksfeste feiern. Und dann ist die Remigration vollzogen worden. Also die sind alle wieder draußen. Und diese Idee ist natürlich bei den Kubitscheks sehr verankert und Krah widerspricht dem jetzt. Und jetzt beziehe ich noch mal auf die Demografie.
Wir sind auch beide kinderreich. Wir haben eine Fertigitätsrate bei den Einwanderern, die ist genauso niedrig in der zweiten Generation wie bei den ethnisch-deutschen. Der Unterschied ist aber, dass Einwanderer immer viel mobiler sind, als alt eingesessen. Das bedeutet, wenn wir keinen weiteren, wir gehen doch davon aus, dass wir die Grenzen zukriegen. Das ist doch die Grundbedingung. Wir brauchen ja über nichts reden, wenn es uns nicht gelingt, die Grenzen zuzumachen und die Einwanderung zu stoppen. Das setzt sich jetzt mal voraus, dass Konsens besteht. Es geht also um die Frage, was passiert an dem Tag, wo der Nachzug gestoppt ist, wo niemand mehr reinkommt. Dann passiert eins, dass diejenigen, die drin sind, ohnehin aufgrund der niedrigen Fertigitätsrate und der höheren Mobilität zahlenmäßig weniger werden als die ethnisch Deutschen, die hierbleiben. Das ist das Erste, was passiert.
Was jetzt also schon mal hier zu erkennen ist, dieses Grenzen schließen, es ist zu viel und Schluss damit. Das ist etwas, was wir jetzt die ganze Zeit ja schon bei der CDU erlebt haben. Jetzt ist nur noch die Frage dann, wie wird bei der CDU irgendwann der Umgang mit jenen aussehen, die schon hier sind. Diese Debatte um die doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft hat schon gezeigt, wie weit man bereit ist, zu gehen, dass man generell Muslimen unterstellt, dass sie eine Nähe zum Antisemitismus haben, sich deshalb noch mal sonderlich bekennen müssen, dass man generell so Äußerungen hat von Christian Lindner. Wir erinnern uns, ja, ich bin mir unsicher, wer da in der Schlange, in der Bäckerei vor mir steht, wenn die nicht so aussehen wie ich, ja, also jetzt paraphrasiert, dann sind das natürlich auch schon alles eigentlich Segregationsäußerungen, die noch lange nicht so weit gehen, wie das, was Krah jetzt hier artikuliert. Aber man findet ja bestimmt einige Protagonisten der CDU, die da richtungsoffen sind, sage ich mal.
Ja, also das, was hier diskutiert wird, ist ja, was bei Trump auch so die zweite Dimension hat, nämlich diese Vergrämung. Versteck dich, sie kommen, geh nicht auf die Straße, zeig dich nicht, werd unsichtbar und so weiter. Und die Resultate werden wir ja bekommen, also so düster es ist, aber für Axeliteristen. Und wir haben das ja ein paar Mal diskutiert. Ist ja kein ganz unattraktiver Gedankengang, finde ich. Steckt da ja ganz schön viel drin. Wir werden uns noch darüber freuen, dass ein ganzer Ozean zwischen uns und Amerika liegt. Aber wir werden es vorgeführt bekommen, was das bedeutet. Denn diese Art von Remigration, die jetzt auf beiden Seiten hier, also es geht ja nur um Details, aber Aladin El-Mafalani hat es ja durchgerechnet einmal. Was passiert, wenn wir wirklich remigrieren? Angenommen, sie würden einfach freiwillig gehen. Dann fehlen einfach 20 Millionen Menschen in der Altersklasse ab 60, nicht so viele, 5 Prozent so. Aber bei dem Nachwuchs, die nächsten Jahrgänge, 30, 40 Prozent. Also das ist, klar haben die jetzt hier einen Streit, aber auf beiden Seiten. Es ist wirklich absurd.
Nochmal Krah?
Dass sie kommen nur an die Eingebürgerten nicht. Weil wenn sie die Gleichheit der Staatsbürger angreifen, greifen sie den Staat in seinem Fundament an. Und wenn sie den Staat in seinem Fundament angreifen, wird der Staat derne zeigen.
Ja, das klingt wirklich toll, wie Krah hier einfach, wir haben ja ein positivistisches Recht. Und wenn einmal die Staatsbürgerkunde ausgestellt ist, ist sie ausgestellt. Und eigentlich sagt er ja, wir müssen das in Kultur kämpfen lösen. Also wir erkennen sie so an auf so einer, ja, okay, bürokratisch, hacken dran. Aber jetzt beginnt das Gespräch. Und das ist natürlich absurd. Wie soll das denn aussehen?
Jetzt schaffen wir No-Go Areas. Im Prinzip heißt das ja, Community Building, wir bedeuten Gettos und Orte, wo die anderen nicht mehr hinkommen.
Einen Begriff, den man tatsächlich weltweit verwendet, so interpretiert, dass wir Staatsbürger in zwei Klassen unterteilen. Und wenn das durchkommt, wenn die Leute glauben, Remigration heißt Staatsbürger unterscheiden, werden wir die Zustimmung, die wir zurzeit haben, verlieren.
Das glaube ich ja leider nicht. Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass sie dann nicht unbedingt Zustimmung verlieren. Ich glaube, es geht eher um das Gesetz.
Und der Staat steht über den ethnischen Gruppen. Der Staat steht über den einzelnen Gruppen, die in der Gesellschaft miteinander ringen. Der Staat darf deshalb niemals Partei einer einzelnen Gruppe sein, weil ansonsten würde er sich zu einer Partei innerhalb des Kampfes machen. Das klingt jetzt aber akutropisch nach einer Partei. Der Begriff heißt dazu...
Aber der Staat ist nicht neutral.
Der Staat ist von seinem Selbstbild her... Versteht sich der Staat als Hüter oberhalb der Gesellschaft, der den Rahmen bietet, dass die verschiedenen gesellschaftlichen Gruppen ihre Konflikte und Interessen in einem rechtlichen Rahmen ausdehnen. Das ist das Staatsmodell des Grundgesetzes.
Das ist das Navativ der Altparteien.
Das ist das Staatsmodell des Grundgesetzes.
Da gibt es kein Kommentator, das anders ist.
Das geht noch sehr lange so hin und her. Das spielen wir jetzt nicht an. Interessant ist, dass Krah sagt, es gibt linke Richter. Die machen alles gegen uns. Aber es gibt Richter, die diese Neutralität hochhalten. Die sind zwar nicht auf unserer Seite direkt, aber indem wir uns dem unterordnen, werden die für uns entsprechende Urteilen, weil die sich ans Grundgesetz einverhalten. Das ist von denen kein Kulturkampf oder sonst was. Und Co-Sitzer ist natürlich völlig davon aufgetrieben, weil sie natürlich denkt, dass dieser ganze Staat nur in den Händen von Grünen oder so ist, die gegen sie Politik machen.
Aber ein schöner Wortwechsel damit. Das erinnert an das Grundgesetz, das ist Ihre Meinung. Oder das Morgenmagazin mit Vertretern der Bundesrepublik.
Eigentlich so ein bisschen Dobrindt auch.
Scheuer war das ja damals. Das ist Ihre Meinung.
Entweder die machen weiter Überwachung, Verbot der IB, Verbot des gesamten Vorfeldes, Parteiverbot, die sind nicht verboten. Das ist der nächste Schritt, der käme. Oder aber die sagen, okay, wir kommen so nicht weiter und wir normalisieren. Wir normalisieren die deutschen Rechte. Das ist jetzt der Scheideweg, an dem wir gerade sind.
Normalisierung der deutschen Rechte. Also diese Debatte, die wir jetzt nochmal bekommen, um Verbot und so weiter, könnte von der AfD selbst beendet werden. Das ist also nicht ausreichend würde. Ich kann das nicht juristisch beurteilen. Aber es sieht danach aus, als hat der Jurist Krah erkannt, wo ein Problem tatsächlich liegen könnte. Und wenn vielleicht nicht zur Bundestagswahl, aber doch schon mal vorab Sachen verboten werden. Und du hast ja auch schon immer wieder darauf hingewiesen, also so Verbote. Das wirkt auch noch mal in der Bevölkerung anders. Weil man ja zugleich sagt, okay, der Staat und deine Polizei und so, das ist ja was Konservative hochhalten wollen. Und wenn jetzt plötzlich die also eindringen und sagen, jetzt ist da aber Schluss, ist die Frage, ob man sich damit noch überhaupt halten kann. Und so ein Verbot will man natürlich entgehen. Deswegen bezieht er sich hier noch mal auf das OVG Münster-Urteil.
Dieses Gutachten, ja, ich hab mir den Spaß gemacht, das einmal mir runterzuladen.
Also das vom Verfassungsschutz, davon hält er nichts, dieses Gutachten?
Dann meinen Namen einzugeben und zu schauen, was sie haben. Der Maßstab, an dem wir uns orientieren können, ist OVG Münster. Und da bleiben eben diese drei Punkte. Gleichheit der Staatsbürger, Religionsfreiheit auch für Muslime und keine allgemeine und umfassende Staatsfeindlichkeit im Sinne so eines libertären, der Staat muss weg. Das sind drei Punkte, mit denen man leben kann.
Das ist die Normalisierung. Er sagt es den beiden noch mal ganz ausdrücklich.
Wer sagt, mit dem Urteil kann ich nicht leben, der kann unter in diesem Staat offensichtlich nicht Politik machen. Also der kann, den wird man verwehren, wird man kalt machen, wird man das verbieten und so weiter. Also entweder man springt über diese drei Stöckchen, die ich nicht schon zu hoch halte oder aber man sagt, okay, Illegalität.
Er promptet sich so rein in die Normalisierung.
Ja, das ist so erstaunlich. Dann auch noch mal ein Aspekt, den wir so wenig betrachtet haben. Wir haben noch JD Vance im Ohr. Bei der Ministerial-Sicherheitskonferenz redet er nur darüber. Ja, und in Deutschland, wie geht man da mit einer demokratisch gewählten Partei um? Und generell sind die USA, also unter Trump, jetzt sehr pro AfD. Man war ja in gewisser Weise schon ganz erleichtert, dass Friedrich Merz nicht AfD-Videos gucken musste, gemeinsam mit Donald Trump. Aber es ist natürlich so, dass man davon ausgehen kann, dass Merzbesuch auch eine kleine Konfrontation dann provoziert hat. Dann nicht vor laufenden Kameras. Aber dass man auch noch mal gesagt hat, also mit der AfD, das dürft ihr nicht machen. Denn Krah sagt hier...
Als die Hochstufung der AfD kam, hat sich der US-Außenminister, der US-Vize-Außenminister, der US-Vize-Präsident geäußert. Das hat es noch nie gegeben.
Noch nie.
Das Auswärtige Amt hat Kopf gestanden in Berlin.
Also fragt sich auch, ob die CDU da bereit ist, Zugeständnisse aus guter transatlantischer Partnerschaft zu machen. Wir wissen ja, wie nahe Jens Spahn den Republikanern schon steht. Krah hat noch eine Anekdote, um noch mal zu sagen, also es gibt natürlich auch Leute, die lehnen uns einfach ab.
Ich war jetzt in Berlin, weil ich mich schön für sie machen wollte, habe ich mir die Haare schneiden lassen. Als ich in dem Friseur bin und man gab mir ein Glas Wasser, weil ich warten sollte, stand jemand auf und sagte, ich bin nicht bereit, in einem Raum zu sitzen, wo dieser Mann sitzt. Diese Leute haben wir. Die haben wir massiv. Das ist das eine. Das Zweite, was wir haben, ist, wir haben aber auch genau die, von denen ich berichtete, die uns zwar nicht wählen, die aber sagen, ja meine Güte, die sind halt da, lass sie machen, die Welt wird nicht untergehen. Und es gibt einen Kampf zwischen diesen beiden Leuten.
Ja, aber das finde ich doch schön ironisch, dass er einen mega langen Podcast aufnimmt, um zu sagen, ich will jetzt mal begründen, warum ich, wenn ich in einen Friseur reingehe, mit dem Finger auf jemanden zeige, um zu sagen, ich kann nicht hier sein, solange sie hier sind, ob sie jetzt auch deutsch sind, ist es mir egal.
Nein, der Gast hat das.
Ja, genau. Also er möchte aussortieren. Aber wenn er den Salon betritt und dann kommt jemand und sagt, also mit dem nicht, dann nix nicht. Kultur kann man nur einseitig führen, sonst wird es ja gefährlich und blöd.
Eben, also das ist natürlich jetzt hier noch gar nicht gesprochen. Sie sprechen ja von einem deutschen Volk als eine auch Meinungshomogenität. Sie müssten ja auch jetzt sich mal fragen, wie kann das eigentlich sein? Unterliegen alle anderen, die jetzt nicht die AfD gewählt haben, in einer Gehirnwäsche. Die würden, der Vorsitzende würde wahrscheinlich sagen, ja. Aber es ist ja ganz interessant, dass sie so eine Homogenität herstellen, wo eigentlich ja eine große, sagen wir, Heterogenität vorhanden ist, zumindest was Meinungen, Auffassungen und Grundsätze anbelangt. Jetzt den letzten Clip, und der sollte uns wirklich zu denken geben. Er nennt den Ort nicht, wo er sich da getroffen hat. Er hat da irgendwie mit dem Landrat zu tun gehabt, der AfD-Landrat ist. Sagt, Deutschland geht es wirtschaftlich schlecht. Die kleinen mittleren Betriebe, Echzen, wissen wir alles. Und Krah war da bei denen zu Gast. Offenbar recht clandestin, also sonst würde er das ja beim Namen nennen. Und Normalisierung, wie kann die eigentlich aussehen? Das bekommen wir jetzt hören, das ist genau eine Normalisierung, wie wir sie sonst hören, wenn die CDU mal wieder irgendwie den kleinen Unternehmer, den Mittelstand und sonst so getroffen hat.
Und haben mich dann eingeladen, dann saß ich in einem größeren Unternehmen mit der Unternehmerelite des Landkreises. Das sind die Leute, die jetzt aufgrund der Krise anfangen, zu uns dazu zu kommen. Und wenn sie mit diesen Leuten reden, ist es natürlich so, da ist noch viel Berührungsangst. Und das Wichtigste, was die erst mal mitnehmen, ist, dass wir normale Menschen sind, die mit Messer und Gabel essen und in einem normalen Tonfall sprechen und nicht nur rumbrüllen.
Normalisierung, das bedeutet also, die antifaschistische Wirtschaftspolitik von Isabella Weber sollte auch genau das mit, glaube ich, im Blick nehmen, dass das eine ganz große Gefahr ist, dass von diesem deutschen Kapital, Familie, Unternehmer und, und, und etwas ausgeht, was auch eine Normalisierung der AfD beschleunigen könnte.
Ja, aber im Metatext, also man hört diese Diskussion. Wie lange haben die da gesprochen?
Knapp zwei Stunden.
Zwei Stunden. Wir haben jetzt Tucker Carlson gegen Ted Cruz, auch zwei Stunden. Du hast es gehört. Das sind die, die uns sagen, es gibt da so ethnische kulturelle Einheiten. Wo man sich nicht streitet, wo man sich versteht, wo man sich wiedererkennt. Und die haben uns wunderbar vorgeführt, wie das nicht stimmt. Sehr gut. Ich möchte auch nochmal was Politisches ansprechen. Typischerweise interessieren wir uns nicht für Polen. Wie ist das Klima eigentlich bei euch?
Also kühl wird jetzt keiner sagen.
Also ich frage nicht, weil ich es kühler machen kann. Ich frage nur.
Also wenn jemand hier im Raum ist, vielleicht da oben, dass man es etwas kühler machen kann, dann wäre das nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube, die laufen bestimmt auch. Also hier vorne an der Ecke müsste es schön kühl sein, weil hier dieses Ding steht.
Ah ja, okay.
Gut, haltet durch. Wer hat Ahnung von Polen? Da fand eine Präsidentenwahl statt. Kennt jemand die Namen? Niemand.
Doch, doch, doch, hinten mehr.
Eine Person. Okay, gut. Wir steigen auch nicht tiefer ein. Sie werden zwar hier genannt, aber sie sollten uns in dem Fall jetzt mal egal sein. Polen ist nur für uns jetzt wichtig, weil es unser Nachbarland ist, weil sie eigentlich unter diese Ethnodefinitionen so ein bisschen mitfallen. Also sie würden uns jetzt nicht sofort auf der Straße erkennen, außer sie fangen an zu reden.
Hätte ich auch noch mal einen Clip, da gehört es Kubitschek über die großartigen Ruhrpolen. Aber das lassen wir jetzt mal.
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel. Also wir erinnern uns, 1. Juni, es werden Ergebnisse verkündet von einer Präsidentenwahl. Allerdings ist in Polen nicht so wie in Deutschland, dass es alle fünf Minuten neue Hochrechnungen gibt und man dann irgendwann Bescheid weiß.
Sollte Letzterer die Stichwahl gewinnen, könnte das nicht nur eine Fortsetzung der Blockadepolitik in Polen bedeuten, sondern auch in der EU. Über das Kopf-an-Kopf-Rennen, Anna Feist.
Also es gibt ein Kopf-an-Kopf-Rennen.
Ein Wahlkrimi im Finale und eines sei vorweggenommen. Wir werden wohl bis morgen warten müssen, um den Ausgang zu erfahren. Nach der ersten Prognose liegt der linksliberale Oberbürgermeister von Warschau, Czarskowski mit 50,3 Prozent ganz knapp vorne.
Wir haben gewonnen, wir haben Geschichte geschrieben, aber das war auf Messers Schneide.
Doch auch das rechte Lager um Politikneuling Nawrodzki gibt sich zu Recht hoffnungsvoll. Wir werden ihnen die Macht nicht überlassen, wir werden in dieser Nacht gewinnen, wir wissen, dass das passieren wird. Das Gebot der Stunde, abwarten, wie die Polen gestimmt haben.
Also es steht 50,50 an diesem Abend. Die Namen sind mir Nawrodzki, Czarskowski oder so. Das ist auch kaum zu unterscheiden. Also es ist alles... Stefan, 49,51.
Bei uns heißen auch alle nur Schmitt und Schulz. Ja.
Ich werde noch mal die Clips rausholen, wie die Amerikaner glauben, dass der deutsche Bundeskanzler gerade heißt.
Ach so.
Gerhard Furzelmeier hat Kohlberg gesagt. Und das stimmt ja auch. Also es ist sehr knapp und es ist unentschieden. Und man dachte aber erst, es geht in die eine Richtung, dann vielleicht doch in die andere. Man hat die Zeit ein bisschen gefüllt, indem man uns noch mal O-Töne-Wortspenden von der Straße vorgespielt hat. Wer tritt da eigentlich gegen wen an?
In diesem Varschawal-Viertel leben viele Czaskowski-Anhänger. Sie geben ihre Stimme Herrn Bonjour, dem Pro-Europäer, der fließend fünf Sprachen spricht. Ich stimme für Czaskowski, für das kleinere Übel. Wenn Nawrodzki gewinnt, dann bedeutet das eine schlimme Zukunft. Als Wähler muss man sich ja schämen, wenn so jemand unser Land repräsentieren soll. Wir wollen nicht von so einem irrsinnigen Prol regiert werden. Raus aus der Großstadt. Wir wollen die kennenlernen, die Karol Nawrodzki wählen. Reise ins ländliche Polen, nicht durch Osten. Fast jeder Zweite hier hat in der ersten Wahlrunde die Historiker mit guten Kontakten ins Rotlichtmilieu seine Stimme gegeben. Wir wählen definitiv Karol Nawrodzki, Dr. Karol Nawrodzki. Das ist ein rechtschaffender Mensch, ein wahrer Patriot.
Wir glauben daran, dass er Polen rettet, dass er die Migration aufhält, die für uns sehr gefährlich ist.
Mit der Angst vor Migration und der Sorge über die innere Sicherheit überzeugte der rechte Präsidentschaftskandidat das Rentnerpärchen. Ich finde, unsere westliche Grenze sollte sehr gut bewacht sein, so wie die östliche. Wir sollten nicht erlauben, dass sie uns aus Deutschland Migranten in unser Land bringen.
So.
Relativ leicht, die Namen eigentlich zu unterscheiden. Der rechte ist Naprotski, der linksliberale Traskowski. Auch wenn ich es jetzt nicht ganz korrekt.
Du bist ja auch ein Mann von Welt.
Bitte?
Ich frage mich immer noch, wie wird man Historiker mit guten Beziehungen zum Rotlichtmilieu?
Ja, genau. Diese Frage ist ja so zu beantworten. Wir haben hier, vor allem sein Erfolg, wir haben hier eine Gemengelage, in der auf der einen Seite jemand sagt, ich spreche fünf Sprachen, nennt mich Mr. Bonjour oder so. Und ich verstehe mich mit ganz Europa. Und auf der anderen Seite, ich kenne Polen so gut, selbst wo ihr angeblich nicht hinschaut, kenne ich mich aus. Es ist unsere Kultur, es ist unser Rotlicht, unser, unser, unser. Und dann sitzen Frauen auf dem Land und sagen, der hält die westliche Grenze, also die zur Deutschland, sozusagen clean, der führt diesen Kulturkampf. Und jetzt haben wir eben schon diese Wahlergebnisse gehört. Es sah ja so aus, als ob dieser Mr. Bonjour gewinnt.
Und auch aus Deutschland wird die Wahl beobachtet. Hier leben rund zwei Millionen Menschen mit polnischen Wurzeln. Sie stellen damit die zweitstärkste Migrantengruppe in Deutschland. Natalie Steger beobachtet die Wahl für uns in Warschau. Natalie, wie belastbar ist denn jetzt diese Prognose? Ich meine, 0,6 Prozentpunkte Vorsprung ist nicht gerade viel.
Nein, da muss man tatsächlich noch sehr, sehr vorsichtig sein. Vor allem wissen wir aus vergangenen Wahlen in Polen, dass die ersten Prognosen oft das rechte Lager unterschätzt haben. Also da ist der statistische Fehler durchaus noch möglich. Jetzt sieht das hier so in Polen aus, dass jetzt nicht wie in Deutschland regelmäßig Hochrechnungen über diesen Abend verteilt werden, sondern das war die erste Prognose nach der Wahl an den Wahllokalen. Und die nächste Prognose, die gibt es erst ab 23 Uhr. Und wahrscheinlich weiß man wirklich erst morgen, wer gewonnen hat, auch wenn beide sich so ein bisschen schon als Sieger präsentieren.
Ja, wir haben hier so einen deutschen Sing-Sang, der einfach sagt, ja, das ist so eng, hier gibt es noch so statistisch, wir müssen das jetzt mal abwarten. Dabei haben wir es hier mit handfester faktischer Politik zu tun. Also da ist einfach ein sehr großer, also so klein, die das darstellen mit 0,6 Prozent und so, wenn man sich das Lager anschaut, da liegen Welten dazwischen. Also diese Enge, die sollte doch eigentlich so gar nicht gegeben sein.
Also du meinst jetzt, dass also die, die nach Rotsky wählen, so fundamental anders denken und sind als diejenigen, die jetzt Traskowski wählen.
Das sind hier amerikanische Verhältnisse, will ich damit sagen. Das sind echte Lagerunterschiedene.
Das ist ja eigentlich das, was auch die Kubitscheks jetzt toll finden. Die sagen ja auch mehrmals dann in diesem Podcast, Neukölln ist das Problem, aber da sind ja dann auch jetzt die Communities unter sich. Man muss sich jetzt halt nur dann von diesen Orten fernhalten und deswegen ist diese Bewegung hin aufs Land natürlich die, die wir hier auch sehen können. Die Reporter müssen ja auch erst mal aufs Land rausgehen, um Anhänger von Navrovsky zu finden.
Genau, also das kostet dann auch alles ein bisschen Zeit und Geld und so, da überhaupt mal die Kunde einzuholen. Dann am nächsten Tag Sendungseröffnung, das 0,6%-Blatt hat sich doch noch gedreht.
Guten Abend, es hatte ja Warnungen gegeben, nicht nur von politischen Gegnern, sondern auch von Juristen, dass die von der neuen Bundesregierung umgehend in Gang gesetzten Zurückweisungen von Asylbewerbern vor Gerichten nicht standhalten würden. Bundeskanzler Merz und Bundesinnenminister Dobrindt haben sie trotzdem angewiesen. Nun gab es dazu heute eine erste Gerichtsentscheidung. Nach einer Eilentscheidung des Berliner Verwaltungsgerichts...
Sorry, ich hab gerade diesen einen Clip übersprungen, denn das Ergebnis hat natürlich hier, glaube ich, verkündet, wo auch noch mal so ein bisschen, also ganz wenige Insights kommen.
Justin, jetzt nehmen wir mal an, Nawrodzki würde sich am Ende durchsetzen. Was würde das für die deutsch-polnischen Beziehung bedeuten?
Na, Karol Nawrodzki ist ein Nationalist, einer der Polen als Polen first. Das ist sein Wahlkampf-Slogan gewesen. Also Polen zuerst ersetzt auf nationalistische Töne und auch vor allem auf anti-deutsche Töne. Da ist er ganz in der Tradition der PiS, der Partei, die ihn aufgestellt hat und die ihn unterstützt als Präsidentschaftskandidat. Also es ist schon davon auszugehen, dass er als Präsident nicht unbedingt für ein harmonisches deutsch-polnisches Miteinander sorgen wird, sondern gerade auch mit Blick auf die nächsten Parlamentswahlen, die ja dann schon in zwei Jahren anstehen, mit anti-deutschen Tönen Stimmung machen wird und da auch mit diesen Emotionen bei den Wählern in seinem Lager umstimmen werben wird. Und das wird für das deutsch-polnische Verhältnis sicherlich nicht einfach werden.
So, er hat ja am Ende gewonnen. Es kam ja am nächsten Tag die Meldung. Dieser Rotlicht-König, da hat gewonnen. Was ja bedeutet, es ist ja total verrückt. Wir schauen immer nach Amerika, weil wir da so sehen, ey, das ist ja voll paradox. Da wird so eine Wahl gemacht, in dem die GUP als Magabewegung sagt, Big Government muss vorbei sein. Wir gehen die Themen durch. Das muss alles zurück in die Bundesstaaten. Die haben die Rechte darauf und so. Und dann zwei Monate nach der Wahl steht plötzlich der föderale Staat von Washington & Sands in Kalifornien auf der Straße. Und Bigger war das Government nie. So, es hat also Konsequenzen. Und hier in Deutschland ist so, ja gut, es regelt halt März, was solls. Müssen wir halt die nächste Chance abwarten oder so. Wird uns jetzt nicht groß betreffen, wie auch immer. Und ich würde da gern sagen, nein, es ist ganz anders. Denn zum einen, wenn in Polen jetzt schon gewarnt wird, in zwei Jahren gibt es eine Parlamentswahl und da wird das anti-deutsche Ressentiment der Treiber sein. Und wir kennen ja die Vorgehensweise, die Konservativen bis hin zu Polen-Försten und so, die setzen dann die Themen. Und daneben stehen dann so die progressiven Kräfte und versuchen eigentlich nur daran, noch so ein bisschen rumzuarbeiten, sich dagegen zu wenden. Aber so eine eigene Idee hat da schon gar keinen Platz mehr und so. Und die Konsequenzen von dieser Polenwahl, allein dadurch, dass wir hier wieder einen Präsident haben, der ja ein bisschen mehr als Steinmeier machen kann, also die da auch einfach Gesetze gar nicht aus durchgehen lassen, dann in Europa auch was mitzusprechen haben, eigentlich sind diese Friedrich Merz, ist jetzt Bundeskanzler für Europa, genauso wirkmächtig wie Donald Trump regiert Amerika. Nur sehen wir es noch nicht so richtig. Und ich möchte jetzt die These aufstellen, das lag an Deutschland. Diese 0,6 Prozent, das lag an der neuen deutschen Bundesregierung. Wenn wir eine Bundesregierung gehabt hätten, die einfach durchgehalten hätte bis September und dann hätten wir eine reguläre Wahl gehabt, wäre das in Polen jetzt anders ausgegangen. Und das kann man hieran zeigen. Jetzt kommen wir zu Maria Daslomka.
Guten Abend. Es hatte ja Warnungen gegeben, nicht nur von politischen Gegnern, sondern auch von Juristen, dass die von der neuen Bundesregierung umgehend in Gang gesetzten Zurückweisungen von Asylbewerbern vor Gerichten nicht standhalten würden. Bundeskanzler Merz und Bundesinnenminister Dobrindt haben sie trotzdem angewiesen. Nun gab es dazu heute eine erste Gerichtsentscheidung. Nach einer Eilentscheidung des Berliner Verwaltungsgerichts ist die Zurückweisung von Asylsuchenden rechtswidrig. Auch könne sich die Bundesregierung dabei nicht auf eine nationale Notlage berufen.
So, also wir haben einen Bundestagswahlkampf, in dem einfach gesagt wird, am Tag eins schicke ich die alle nach Polen. Das wird natürlich in Polen anders gehört. Dann sind diese Wahlen gelaufen und plötzlich heißt es, also die Deutschen kriegen da zwar so ein eigenes Urteil vorgesetzt, aber sie halten sie einfach nicht dran. Dann dürfen wir Polen das ja wohl auch. So ungefähr. Und diese deutsche Politik, die ist, und jetzt lassen wir mal so diese These mitlaufen, genauso irre wie das, was wir bei Trump sehen, nur, dass wir noch so einen Verfassungsrahmen haben, der das so ein bisschen containt. Der Gorilla steht im Bild, aber noch hinter Gittern.
Wir haben ja schon gesehen, bei Krah, mit den Gerichten ist nicht zu spaßen mitunter.
Genau, also wir bereiten uns ja vor auf eine Zukunft, in der Jens Spahn die CDU führt, nicht über seinen Mastenskandal gestolpert ist und dann mit Krah irgendwie Hand in Hand in den Bundestag einmarschiert. Und so. Hier sehen wir die Anfänge.
Wie hier soll es an allen deutschen Grenzen weitergehen, wie seit knapp vier Wochen, wie seit Amtsantritt der neuen Bundesregierung, Grenzkontrollen und Zurückweisungen auch von Asylsuchenden. Dabei hat das Verwaltungsgericht Berlin diese Praxis heute für rechtswidrig erklärt, sie verstoße gegen EU-Recht.
Ja, aber das soll einfach so weitergehen. Aber es ist doch sowieso schon irre, 14.000 Polizisten mit Hubschraubern hin und her zu fliegen, um 130 Leute zurückzudrängen. Und jetzt kriegen die auch noch das Urteil. Und es geht trotzdem immer so weiter. Also wir haben es ja wirklich mit ganz Verrückten. Jetzt hören wir Dobrindt, wie er das so ein bisschen erklärt.
Eine juristische Niederlage für Innenminister Dobrindt, der die Zurückweisung von Asylsuchenden noch am Tag seine Amtsübernahme angeordnet hatte. Er sieht dennoch keinen Grund daran, nun etwas zu ändern.
Wir halten im Übrigen an den Zurückweisungen fest. Wir sehen, dass die Rechtslohnklage gegeben ist und werden deswegen weiter so verfahren, ganz unabhängig von dieser Einzelfallentscheidung.
Aha, ist nur so eine Einzelfallentscheidung. Jetzt hören wir mal so ein Polizeigewerkschaft. Was bedeutet das eigentlich für die Praxis?
Die Bundespolizei macht also weiter, aber mit einem Grummeln im Magen, so der Gewerkschafter.
Natürlich ist es jetzt ein Einzelfall, aber es ist ein klassischer Fall, der durch das Gericht beleuchtet worden ist, der viele Male am Tag passiert, in der Woche passiert. Und von dem her darf es so nicht weitergehen. Die Kollegen brauchen klare rechtliche Sicherheit.
Ja, kennen wir so ein bisschen aus Amerika. Also da ist einfach die städtische Polizei Los Angeles. Und ein paar Leute davon sind aber auch in der Nationalgarde. Wenn sie aktiviert werden, dann werden die halt Abgeordnete, sind plötzlich keine Polizisten mehr, sondern Nationalgarde. Damit unterstehen sie aktuell noch dem Präsidenten, auch wenn das gerade juristisch geklärt wird, unter wem jetzt eigentlich die Nationalgarde da formiert. Was aber künftig bedeuten kann, dass einfach vom Gouverneur oder von der Bürgermeisterin beauftragte Polizisten gegen dieselben Personen, aber plötzlich in einer anderen Uniform. Und dann wissen die gar nicht, welcher Befehl geht denn jetzt eigentlich, wer ist denn hier für mich zuständig? Und die sagen jetzt, ich soll die und ja, also in solche brenzlichen Situationen. Aber die Bundespolizei muss das jetzt so mit Grummeln im Bauch machen. Die kennen natürlich das Urteil und wissen aber auch, klar, es geht nur für den Einzelfall, aber jeder Einzelfall wird künftig genauso entschieden, weil das natürlich voll inhaltlich das Präzedenzurteil ist. Also das ist wirklich wahnsinnig verrückt.
Ja, man kann ja auch nochmal so was Prinzipielles zur Polizei sagen. Also dass die Polizei ja ohnehin schon immer an der Grenze eigentlich zum Rechtsschritt oder über dieses Recht hinausgeht. Nämlich vieles wird ja nachträglich entschieden, war richtig oder war falsch. Das heißt also so eine permanente Grenzübertretung ist eigentlich der der Polizei immanent. Im Prinzip kann man das schon bei Walter Benjamin und folgenden nachlesen. Und hier nun ist aber das Verrückte, dass quasi schon die Nachträglichkeit sichtbar ist in Form dieses Urteils. Und man sagt aber ja, aber noch nicht für alle anderen Fälle, die wir hier machen. Deswegen machen wir da schon mal weiter. Also man nutzt wirklich diesen Spielraum der Wahrheit, der keiner ist. Also die Zukunft schnappt schon zu, aber wir sind noch nicht ganz da.
Das Urteil ist jetzt auf einer Instanz gesprochen, wo es für sich gilt, für diesen Einzelfall. Und jetzt sagt Dobrindt einfach, naja, es ist ja ein Einzelfall. Wenn Dobrindt jetzt sagen würde, nö, aus inhaltlichen Gründen, weil ich glaube, wir sind im Recht, fechte ich das Urteil an, kommt es auf eine Instanz, bei der es nicht mehr nur für den Einzelfall gilt. Und deswegen macht er das nicht. Also haben wir jetzt ganz viele Einzelfälle, die alle gegen die Bundesregierung urteilen und die Bundesregierung so, naja, okay, dann werden wir halt in dem Fall das befolgen. Wir eskalieren hier nichts, wir sind ganz kuhsam. Also es ist eine ganz perfide Strategie. Wir hören jetzt Friedrich Merz selbst dazu, unser neuer Bundeskanzler, wenige Wochen im Amt.
Als Rückschlepp will die Union das nicht sehen, sondern höchstens als kleinen Dämpfer.
Wir haben gestern eine Entscheidung, eine vorläufige Entscheidung des Verwaltungsgerichts Berlin gesehen, die die Spielräume hier möglicherweise noch einmal etwas einengt. Aber die Spielräume sind nach wie vor da. Wir wissen, dass wir nach wie vor Zurückweisungen vornehmen können. Wir werden das selbstverständlich im Rahmen des bestehenden europäischen Rechts tun. Aber wir werden es tun, auch um die öffentliche Sicherheit und Ordnung in unserem Lande zu schützen.
Das ist wie Trump. Das ist nur noch verfassungs... vom Verfassungstext contain.
Wir sehen hier auch noch mal auf globaler Ebene, dass das Völkerrecht ja auch keine Rolle spielt, wenn Drecksarbeit erledigt werden muss. Zitat Merz, ja. Also das ist immer so, da haben wir plötzlich Spielräume, mit denen wir arbeiten können.
Slomka fragt jetzt relativ klug Thorsten Frei gerade heraus, was zu fragen ist.
Darüber wollen wir reden mit Kanzleramtschef Thorsten Frei. Guten Abend Herr Frei nach Berlin.
Schönen guten Abend Frau Slomka.
Sie kennen den Vorwurf, dass die Bundesregierung jetzt einen Urteil nicht mehr ausreichend beachtet, weil es ihr politisch nicht passt. Das ist ja eine Entwicklung, die wir in den USA aktuell in vieler Hinsicht beobachten. Geht die Bundesregierung jetzt in eine ähnliche Richtung?
Nein, ich finde diesen Zusammenhang kann man überhaupt nicht herstellen. Wir haben ein Urteil eines Verwaltungsgerichtes hier in Berlin und für den konkreten Fall wird es selbstverständlich beachtet. Es ist eine Einzelfallentscheidung bezogen auf drei Somalier und für die wird es jetzt ein normales Dublin-Verfahren geben, so wie es das Gericht angeordnet hat. Aber über den konkreten Fall hinaus hat die Entscheidung eines Verwaltungsgerichts keine weitergehende Wirkung.
Eigentlich müsste man jetzt, wie die Bundesregierung Polizisten platziert an den Grenzen, Juristen an die Grenzen stellen, wenn die sofort einen Einzelfall nach dem anderen produzieren und jedes Mal aus Thorsten Freisagen ja sagen, da haben wir wieder drei, da machen wir natürlich nochmal ein Dublin-Verfahren.
Naja, das Interessante ist, du musst sie ja nicht an die Grenze stellen, sondern du musst ja einfach nur diese Fälle aufgreifen, weil du dir relativ sicher sein kannst als Anwalt heute, diese Dinger gewinnst du immer. In der Ansicht ist das schon wirklich bescheuert, Slumka noch mal gut.
Aber auch ein Verwaltungsgericht ist zuständig für die Umsetzung von EU-Rechten. Insofern klingt das jetzt schon etwas dispektierlich, was Sie sagen, ein Verwaltungsgericht kann keine Regierungspolitik entscheiden.
Ich finde ehrlicherweise nicht, dass es despektierlich klingt, soll es auch nicht, weil ich respektiere selbstverständlich das Urteil. Das ist ja selbstverständlich in einem Rechtsstaat. Und deswegen wird im konkreten Fall das Urteil ja auch umgesetzt. Daran besteht ja überhaupt kein Zweifel.
Nun könnte es ja noch ganz viele solche Urteile geben. Theoretisch können ja mit Unterstützung von Nicht-Regierungsorganisationen noch ganz viele Asylbewerber eben genau diesen Weg gehen, denen jetzt auch die drei Somalier gingen. Und dann haben wir hier irgendwann hunderte solcher Einzelfallentscheidungen. Machen sie dann trotzdem so weiter?
Unterstellen sie jetzt damit, dass alle Urteile so ausgehen, wie dieser Beschluss des Verwaltungsgeber Berlin.
Das Verwaltungsgericht schien sich da recht sicher zu sein. Und wenn man so juristische Beurteilungen liest, scheint zumindest eine Vielzahl von Juristen zu vermuten, dass das in der Tat auch ähnlich so ausgehen wird. Eben weil der EUGH auch schon oft solche Entscheidungen getroffen hat.
Nein, also diese Einschätzung teile ich nicht.
Ah, das ist Ihre Meinung.
Das sind einfach so Meinungen. Die könnte ja auch dran sein, dass so mit dem Rechnunggesetz, dass da ja viel so prinzipiell und formal ist. Also von daher, dass da Parallelen gezogen werden können.
Könnte auch sein, dass diese Richter genau wussten, dass sie natürlich nur für den Einzelfall schreiben und trotzdem 50 Seiten Literatur für alle anderen Gerichte schon mal vorbereitet haben.
Das sind die Richter, vor denen Maximilian Krah auch Angst hat.
Wir gehen natürlich jetzt nicht in diese Textexegese. Wir hören einfach nur die ARD-Experten-Einmeinung.
Die ausführliche Begründung des Berliner Gerichts, die geht weit über den Einzelfall hinaus und deckt sich übrigens mit der Einschätzung sehr vieler Expertinnen und Experten, dass Zurückweisungen rechtswidrig sind. Möglich ist aber, dass noch andere Gerichte zu Fällen an anderen deutschen Grenzen entscheiden. Diese Frage ist also noch nicht abschließend für ganz Deutschland geklärt.
Ja, also wir haben eine Bundesregierung neu, die angetreten ist gegen den Bürokratismus, die jetzt 14.000 Polizisten mit Hubschraubern an irgendeinen grünen Baum stellt und da sagt, hier, das ist übrigens eine Grenze, erkennt das mal und fragt hier jeden und dann fallen 130 raus. Und diese 130 sind auch alle noch rechtsweg. Also die grüne Grenze wird plötzlich zum Rechtsweg und zwar erfolgreich für jeden Einzelfall gegen die Bundesregierung. Aber Containment, es ist eben nicht nur der Verfassungstext, sondern anders als Trump und JD. Vance, gibt es hier noch so Koalitionspartner. Wieso wir da Clip nicht abspielen? Moment. Also es ist einfach nur Mathias Miersch, ihr kennt ihn ja von der SPD, der sagt, ich bin hier nicht nur Opposition, sondern ich habe auch eine Meinung aus der Regierung heraus. Und dieser Einzelfall ist irgendwie da zu Präsidentscharakter.
Ach, sagt er ja.
Oder hören wir das hier in dem?
Innenminister Dobrindt will ja am bisherigen Kurs festhalten, bis zu einer Entscheidung des Europäischen Gerichtshofs. SPD-Fraktionenchef Miersch dagegen, sagte der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Sonntagszeitung, pauschale Zurückweisungen werde es aus seiner Sicht nicht mehr geben können, weil die Gerichte das stoppen würden.
So, also Gegenfeuer aus der eigenen Regierung. Das ist auch eine Containment-Strategie, die wir bei Trump schon nicht mehr sehen. Wir sparen uns mal, ich nenne nur die Zahlen, 14.000 Polizisten, 160 Zurückweisungen. So eine wahnsinnig erfolgreiche Politik, ja, wenn man das aus dieser... So, und jetzt aber dieser Clip, der so entscheidend ist, zurück nach Polen. Wir hören jetzt, wie die Stimmungslage in Polen durch dieses deutsche Regierungshandeln, das hier... Klar, in dem Falle ist auch mal der Journalismus dazu ganz gut gewesen. Aber das tut nicht nur in dem Singensang einfach mitgeht, sondern Tusk hat jetzt diesen residualen Gegenspieler, der ihm, also einfach die Knüppe jetzt in die Weine wirft. Und wir schauen mal, in welchem Zustand der polnische Parlamentarismus dadurch ist, ja, also durch die deutsche Bundesregierung.
Ich bin generell entspannt, sagt er auf dem Weg zur Vertrauensfrage. Seine Rede soll ein Ruck sein. Er betont Erfolge in der Wirtschafts- und Sicherheitspolitik. Ein weiter so, auch nach der Niederlage seines liberalen Präsidentschaftskandidaten. Ich kenne den Geschmack des Sieges und die Bitterkeit der Niederlage, aber das Wort Kapitulation kenne ich nicht. Davon kann keine Rede sein. Seinen Auftritt boykottieren die Abgeordneten der nationalkonservativen PiS, in der Fragestunde dann der Dauervorwurf Tusk als angeblicher Handlanger Deutschlands. Sie haben in Ihrer Rede verschwiegen, dass Sie deutschen und nicht polnischen Interessen dienen. Die Frage ist, warum treten Sie nicht ehrenhaft zurück, anstatt diese dumme Vertrauensfrage zu stellen.
Also Tusk redet als Regierungschef und die PiS ist schon gar nicht mehr anwesend. Da wird einfach die Rede boykottiert. Das ist so, als würde die AfD einfach rausgehen und sagen, ach, Sie sind ja eh nur ein Handlanger Amerikas. Das erkennen wir hier gar nicht an. Wir ziehen uns hier zurück und wir stellen ja übrigens den Präsidenten.
Und Sie machen mit Deutschland gemeinsame Sache. Und die Deutschen geben uns die Migranten zurück.
Und das ist jetzt der Tenor die nächsten zwei Jahre. Das ist quasi schon Wahlkampf für den nächsten parlamentarischen Aufzug hier, in dem die PiS dann eben nicht mehr als Opposition einfach einen Boykott übt, sondern wieder die Regierung stellt. Und das alles so unter der Hand. Und wir kriegen dann so einen deutschen Journalismus, wo so ha ha ha und so. Obwohl das hier im amerikanischen Maßstab eigentlich schon köchelt in Europa. Nur weil wir so Ländergrenzen haben und die Polen, die werden uns schon nichts tun und so, wird das einfach übersehen. Also das sind wirklich gruselige Verhältnisse.
Eine Zeitung, die ja maßgeblich daran mitarbeitet, dass solche verrückten Grenzkontrollen jetzt gekommen sind, ist die BILD-Zeitung, die zum Springer-Konzern gehört. Und der Springer-Konzern wird, wie wir wissen, geführt von Mathias Döpfner. Und im Hintergrund ist noch Friede Springer. Mathias Döpfner ist ein Kritiker gewesen, Musikwissenschaftler, der dann diese unglaubliche Karriere gemacht hat. Friede Springer dann eines Tages kennenlernte und sie sah in ihm den Mann, der diesen Riesenkonzern führen soll. Mathias Döpfner ist inzwischen, so sagt das Chet-GPT auch, Matze Hilscher zitiert es an einer Stelle, der zweitmächtigste Medienmann der Welt. Denn es ist ja nicht nur BILD-Zeitung, BILD und all das. Der Springer-Verlag expandiert enorm gerade in den USA und ersetzt auch ganz auf Journalismus, hat sich ja von den Nebengeschäften, Kleinanzeigen und so etwas jetzt nach der Trennung von KKR getrennt. Also KKR hat das übernommen. Sie haben sich jetzt ganz auf den Journalismus konzentriert. Und ich will hier noch einen kleinen Disclaimer machen. Manchmal wird mir ja vorgeworfen, ja, warum habe ich denn was gegen Gefühle? Also ich habe gar nichts gegen Gefühle. Ja, habe auch selbst welche. Ich habe nur Gefühle der Abwehr, wenn mir Leute kommen, die sagen, ich will jetzt aber mal den Menschen in den Mittelpunkt rücken und nicht den Funktionsträger. Aber Mathias Döpfner ist in seiner Funktion nur interessant. Also menschlich ist das eine Frage, die irgendwie was für seine Ehefrau, seine Kinder oder sonst wie sind oder für seine Freunde. Aber wir leben natürlich in einer Zeit, wo es immer menschelt, nämlich in dem Sinne, jetzt will ich aber mal den Menschen lieber kennenlernen, als das, was er so eigentlich macht. Und er war bei Hotel Matze zu Gast. Und wir hören mal rein, wie so ein Gespräch verläuft mit einem Milliardär, der ja auch fast ohne Steuer zu zahlen, da ein Riesenvermögen inzwischen besitzt. Wir wissen ja, für alles, was die Bildzeiten steht, müssen wir gar nicht runter ratzern jetzt, sondern wir hören gleich mal Mathias Döpfner jetzt hier im Gespräch mit Matze Hielscher.
Dann lass uns doch mal einen Blick in deine Kindheit werfen. Was würdest du sagen, welches Bild fährt dir zuerst ein, wenn du den heutigen Matthias anguckst und den ganz jungen Matthias? Was ist so ein Bild, was beide miteinander verbindet?
Oh je.
Langes Nachdenken.
Ich glaube, es ist so ein... Ich sehe jemanden, der irgendwie auf einem Spazierweg, auf einem Waldweg neugierig irgendwohin läuft. Und das ist eigentlich als Kind, als Kleinkind so gewesen. Und das ist nicht immer noch so. Das prägt jeden Tag von mir eigentlich in gewisser Weise.
Die Neugier, die eine immer noch treibt, auch wenn man 62 Jahre alt ist und so mächtig ist, dann muss man sich diese Neugier bewahren. Und was jetzt hier passiert ist natürlich, dass wir von all dem uns erst mal frei machen sollen für was Springer, Döpfner und so steht, sondern wir sollen jetzt den Menschen kennenlernen. Aber wir wissen ja, dass genau das zu nichts führt. Und um das ganz plastisch zu machen, wir erinnern uns an diese geleakten SMS, die Döpfner geschrieben hat, wo er auch zum Beispiel zum Klimawandel-Stellung bezieht und sagt, kein Problem ist ja, so paraphrasiere ich jetzt, ist eigentlich Wärmephasen waren immer Hochkulturfasen in der Menschheitsgeschichte. Also ist natürlich auch mal ein Blick auf den Klimawandel. Aber wer jetzt meint, also wie kann man eine solche Aussage machen? Ja, gleichzeitig ist Mathias Döpfner natürlich ein Freund der Natur.
Und ich habe den Garten und die Natur geliebt. Und es gab eine Linde in diesem Garten und eine Magnolie. Und die Linde wurde eines Tages gefällt, als ich mal für ein paar Stunden weg war. Und als ich zurückkam, war die Linde weg. Und das habe ich empfunden wie den Verlust eines Menschen. Das war ganz schrecklich. Ich habe tagelang geweint, weil die Linde weg war.
Wow, bist du immer noch so ein Naturmensch? Also kann man sich nicht vorstellen, wenn man so ahnt, welchen Terminkalender du hast?
Ich war erst Gärtner, dann wollte ich mal Förster werden. Und ich bin heute immer noch ein absoluter Garten- und Waldliebhaber. Ich liebe Natur. Natur ist meine Meditation und das macht mich ruhig und das macht mich...
Aggressiv.
Wirklich glücklich.
Wir haben es hier mit dem Chef eines Medienkonglomerats zu tun, das ziemlich vehement gegen eine vernünftige Klimapolitik kämpft. Wir könnten ja jetzt eine Stunde damit verbringen, alle Headlines mal einzublenden gegen die Klimapolitik der Grünen oder so. Also das ist ja wirklich der reinste Wahnsinn, der dort stattfindet. Und gleichzeitig haben wir hier den Landtourliebhaber. Dann denkt man sich, wie passt das zusammen? Dann denkt man, ja, doch, das passt eigentlich gut zusammen, wenn man nämlich einfach trennt. Es gibt die Charaktermaske, würde Marc sagen, also die Funktion, die er zu auszuüben hat. Im Kapitalismus. Und dann gibt es irgendwie den privaten kleinen Mathias, der gerne in die eine Richtung läuft und Bäume umarmt und sonst was tut. Es gibt ein berühmtes Stück von Berthold Precht, Herr Puntila und sein Knecht Matty. Und Herr Puntila ist also der Kapitalist und der hat diese wunderbare Eigenschaft, dass, wenn er betrunken ist, er unglaublich menschlich ist und auch Matty immer viel verspricht und allen anderen. Und dann wird er aber wieder nüchtern. Das heißt, er wird wieder zum Kapitalisten und dann tut er das, was getan werden muss. Also so ein Podcast verunglärt natürlich unglaublich die Situation, in der wir sind, weil wir können eigentlich Mathias Döpfner nicht auf der menschlichen Ebene begegnen. Denn das führt zu nichts. Aber Mathias Döpfner hat auch ein paar Leitlinien, die wichtig sind. Zum Beispiel?
Ein besonderes Verhältnis zu Widerspruch. Ich halte den Widerspruch was extrem Produktives zum Nein sagen, zum fast schon automatisch, wenn alle einer Meinung sind, mal das andere verproben. Ich halte es für eine absolute Grundeigenschaft von gutem Journalismus. Also wenn die meisten das sagen, sage ich es auch noch, dass es langweilig und bringt dann überhaupt nicht weiter. Journalistische Neugier ist, wenn alle dieser Meinung sind, dann gucke ich mal, ob nicht das Gegenteilrichtung ist. Wenn alle das behaupten, dann gucke ich mal, ob es wirklich stimmt oder ob es nicht ganz anders sein könnte. Und das basiert ja alles auf diesem Impetus Nein. Also dieses Einverstandensein ist was oberigkeitshöriges.
Und da ist ja die BILD-Zeitung für bekannt, dass sie so viel Widerspruch zulässt. Also wenn dann nur so eine minimal abweichende Position zu Nahost vertreten wird, dann wird man ja sofort eingehegt.
Also ich war ja schon einige Male damals in einem Raum mit Mathias Döpfner und ich weiß auch, wie über ihn geredet wird, wenn Menschen auf seine Augenhöhe sagen, warte mal, das hat er schon wieder öffentlich gesagt, weil er damals immer so Zeitungspräsident war und so. Und diese Idee von Mathias Döpfner ist der, der dann in der laufenden Diskussion nein sagt, ist wirklich das Grotesk. Das ist derjenige, dem einfach völlig egal ist, was der Raum sagt, sondern der rausgeht und ein Statement macht. Und zwar für alle spricht. Für die ganze Menschheit.
Aber er ist eigentlich ein Anti-Autoritärer. Also das ist eine völlig merkwürdige Darstellung von dir jetzt hier. Hör mal zu.
Aber eine Autorität, die sich ableitet von institutioneller Macht oder der schieren Tatsache, dass der eine dem anderen vorgesetzt ist oder mehr Macht oder mehr Geld hat als der andere, das ist eine Autorität, die ich sehr unangenehm finde und von der ich meine, dass sie von denen, gegen die sie ausgeübt wird, immer hinterfragt und sozusagen herausgefordert werden muss. Und diejenigen, die sie ausüben oder ausüben wollen, müssen sich eigentlich immer darüber umplanen, dass es eigentlich ein Zeichen von Schwäche ist. Also wenn ich nur meine Hierarchie und meine institutionelle Macht dazu verwende, etwas durchzusetzen, dann scheine ich keine guten Argumente zu haben.
Ja, in diesem Moment der Ehrlichkeit möchte ich euch gestehen, ich liebe ja Podcasts, das ist über mich bekannt, aber diese fünfstündigen Formate, wo zwei Leute ohne noch mal mit einem Interviewgast das zurückzukoppeln, dann so, das kann ich gar nicht leiden. Das ist eigentlich für den letzten Schrott. Das muss zack, zack, zack, zack, jeden Morgen, beisenherzartig. Dann ist es richtig gut.
J.
Schumacher hat dann noch mal konkretiert, dass er ja viel zu alt ist und so.
Aber das, was wir machen, ich finde es unglaublich und muss aber jetzt auch wirklich mich fragen, bei Matze Hielscher, also man kann sich ja in Leute hineinfühlen wollen und so was. Okay, das ist das Konzept der Sache. Aber man kann ja nicht voll ins naiv rein gehen. Also das ist ja nun ein sehr mächtiger Mann. Und egal, wie man dazu stehen würde, selbst wenn man das toll findet, was er erreicht hat oder wie was BILD macht, dann muss man ja doch festhalten, dass man eine solche Position genau so nicht erreicht, wie das jetzt gerade artikuliert ist. Also wenn jetzt Matze Hilscher dort einen Zehnkämpfer setzen hätte und der würde sagen, also ich schlaf zwölf Stunden, esse meistens bei McDonalds und Fahrrad fahren und laufen, ist nicht so meins, dann würde er ja auch dem nicht glauben, dass man damit eine Goldmedaille gewinnt. Und das ist ja, also jeder, der ja mal in kleineren Strukturen irgendwie Vorgesetzte, Chefs erlebt hat, weiß ja, was diese Strukturen selbst hervorbringen. Da muss man noch gar nicht die besonders autoritäre Person sein. Aber wie kommt man überhaupt dahin? Ich hatte jetzt natürlich als Interview gefragt, welche Rolle spielt denn eigentlich da Friede Springer und dass man da plötzlich so ein schönes Erbe schon früh ausgezahlt bekommt und plötzlich so ganz, ganz reich ist. Aber nee.
Natürlich ist es so, dass ich also erstmal, ich habe halt wahnsinnig viel gearbeitet. Ganz einfach und ich musste übrigens ziemlich alt werden, um festzustellen, dass das eine zu unrecht vernachlässigte oder diskreditiert diskreditierte Erfolgsvoraussetzungen ist. Einfach, hart arbeiten ist very simple.
Gut, Friede Springer selbst hat ja geheiratet. Das war die harte Arbeit, die da verbracht wurde. Jetzt kommen natürlich auf diese Affäre Julian Reichelt, hätte man zu sprechen. Er war ja vor einer Weile schon bei UMR. Da ging es dann auch um die Reichelt-Affäre. Also ich würde ja fast jetzt so, wenn ich jetzt Verschwörungstheoretiker wäre, würde ich ja sagen, es war ein Inside-Job. Weil das jetzt so ideal ist, eigentlich für alle Leute von Springer, die irgendwie in Interviews sind. Die werden nicht mehr kritisch befragt, überhaupt zu Springer, was Springer alles macht, sondern nur noch diese Affäre Reichelt, dass da der Chefredakteur mit den Mitarbeiterinnen so und so umgesprungen ist und das war nicht okay und macht Missbrauch. Das ist das Einzige, was jetzt noch thematisiert wird. Davon hat man sich ja glücklicherweise befreit. Und damit ist man jetzt eigentlich fein raus. Also sei das jetzt so das einzige Manko in dieser glorreichen Unternehmensgeschichte gewesen. Aber man hat natürlich auch immer Learnings bei sowas.
Was würdest du sagen, du hast mal gesagt, dass du ziemlich gut darin bist, deine eigenen Fehler zu erklären. Was waren hier an der Stelle deine Fehler?
Das klingt vielleicht zu.
Also das ist natürlich auch das höchste Zeichen von Macht, wenn man es schafft, so zu sprechen und trotzdem hört einem jemand gebannt zu oder muss zuhören. Dann hat man es geschafft.
Komisch oder unglaubwürdig. Aber es ist wirklich so, ich glaube, dass es vertrauenbar ist. Das Vertrauen ist eine Stärke von mir, dass ich sehr schnell und leicht vertrauen kann. Ich glaube, das motiviert auch Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter, gerne mit mir zusammen zu arbeiten und alles zu geben. Aber ich vertraue halt manchmal auch dann im falschen Moment.
Das war der Fehler in der Reichelt-Affäre.
Das Vertrauen besteht ja darin, dass da oben so ein vierköpfiger Vorstand sitzt, von dem drei Köpfe wissen, eigentlich sind wir nur ein einköpfiger Vorstand und so. Und wir kennen doch die SMSn. Mach mal hier die FDP und so weiter. Das ist doch kein Vertrauen, sondern das ist einfach nur der Typ, das ist wie Trump und Hexed. Hexed hat nichts zu melden. Trump steuert das alles aus dem weißen Haus. Und so ist das ja auch. Da saß halt jemand, der auf Zuruf, mach mal hier die FDP klein, mach mal das, mach mal das und so. Aber Vertrauensverhältnis.
Eine kritische Note gibt es dann doch, oder zumindest merkt Matze auch, das stimmt doch, das irgendwie, kriegt das alles nicht so zusammen.
Ist, dass ich im Vorfeld versucht habe, mit ein paar Menschen zu sprechen. Das versuche ich immer, das kennst du ja auch. Man sagt, aber eben kennt man. Und ich war überrascht, dass mit mir keiner reden wollte. Und auch so ein bisschen so, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Da will ich nicht. Das ist nicht so ein gutes Zeichen. Das ist auch das, was ich im ersten Mal hatte. Das kriege ich auch nicht mit dem Bild, was ich von dir jetzt gerade habe. Das kriegt das nicht zusammen. Aber dieses Bild gibt es ja auch.
Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr, ein Clip für die Ewigkeit. Ja, denn das ist Döpfner. Wenn Matze Hilscher, von dem alle wissen, super mächtig durch Reichweiten Stark Podcast, so, wenn der auf dich zukommt und sagst Hallo, ich rede morgen mit Matthias Döpfner, kann ich mit dir ein Vorgespräch führen?
Du bist doch mit dem befreundet oder?
Da sagt einfach jeder Sorry, ich habe mir jetzt gerade den Fuß gebrochen. Ich habe eine Krebsdiagnose, ich muss sofort zum Arzt. Also da wird richtig groß aufgefallen. Das sind eigentlich die Geschichten, die ich von Matze Hiltje irgendwann noch mal hören will. Was wurde dir genau gesagt, als du kamst, du möchtest mit jemandem über Matthias Döpfner reden?
Döpfner ist aber auch jemand, der ja auch leidet unter all dieser Macht, die er hat.
Das ist, dass ich sehr oft eben in der Funktion, in der Rolle wahrgenommen werde. Und das empfinde ich schon als eine Einschränkung. Weil das ist wie so eine Mauer, die zwischen einem Menschen und einem anderen Menschen steht. Das ist nicht ein Problem bei denen, die mich lange kennen oder die mich wirklich sehr gut kennen, aber bei welchen, die mich nicht kennen, die mich zum ersten Mal sehen, wie die mit mir agieren. Du bist überhaupt nicht so. Also wir unterhalten uns hier total entspannt und du fragst, was du fragen willst. Also das ist sehr angenehm, wirklich.
Der ist zwei Meter fünf oder so groß, über eine Milliarde schwer. Und alle, mit denen er im Raum ist, gucken nur auf ihn, wo er sich gerade befindet. Wie so ein physikalisches Phänomen in so einem Raum. Und dann geht er auf jemanden zu und wundert sich, dass da so eine Mauer dazwischen ist. Also die hat er aufgebaut die ganze Zeit. Das ist sein Nimbus, das ist seine Macht.
Aber die wichtigen Fragen?
Bist du ein guter Vater?
Ich muss dir sagen, wenn ich das nicht wäre, wäre das das größte Versagen meines Lebens. Dass ich natürlich nicht alles richtig gemacht habe, ist völlig klar.
Hier weiß Mathias Döpfner, dass sich Matze Hilscher nicht traut, anzudeuten oder wirklich aufzuführen, was er in Vorgesprächen gehört hat.
Ja, beziehungsweise wir haben ja mal von Interesse gewesen, was ist eigentlich mit dem Sohn und Peter Thiel und so was. Das könnte man ja alles mal besprechen. Döpfner, wie gesagt, leidet.
Leute, die voller Vorurteile und Hass sind, wo ich mir denke, du kennst mich doch gar nicht. Was denkst du? Ja, du bist ein CEO. Du bist Kapitalist. Du bist schwinger, BILD, grauenvoll. Einen Klischee nach dem anderen kann ja nur ein Monster sein. Ein Finsterling, der mit den Bösen dieser Welt konspiriert, um den Planeten so einen schlechten zu machen. Ich lerne dich erst mal kennen. Du kennst mich doch gar nicht.
Ja, das ist das Interessante. Ich kann gar nicht. Mathias Döpfner, ich habe ihn ja noch nie getroffen. Ich kann ihn ja gar nicht beurteilen. Ich müsste ihn ja erst mal kennenlernen. Und das ist genau diese Ideologie, die natürlich auch nicht nur aus diesem Podcast, sondern generell aus der Podcastwelt spricht, dass man einfach sagt, ich will jetzt einfach nur den Menschen kennenlernen und dann weiß ich wirklich, was sie werden. Nee, dann weiß man eigentlich viel weniger. Also man kann ja, ich will jetzt hier keinen Namen nennen, aber man kann sich ja alle schrecklichen Figuren, der Gegenwart oder Geschichte vorstellen, die in einem Podcast irgendeine rührende Geschichte vom Lindenbaum im Garten erzählen. Also das funktioniert ja mit allen, weil das natürlich alles keine Monster, sondern Menschen sind. Das ist logisch.
Aber wenn man das jetzt mal so auf so einer latenten Sinnstruktur-Ebene, was wir gerade gehört haben, es mag ihn keiner kennen können, aber er selbst kann sich wirklich sehr gut beschreiben. Das war wirklich auf dem Punkt gerade.
Wir hören noch seinen Lieblingssatz.
Tatsächlich mein Lieblingssatz, wenn man es auf einen Satz bringen will, was ja unmöglich ist und schwierig ist, aber ich liebe ihn wirklich und ich finde ihn so wahr, ist von Perikles, das Geheimnis des Glücks ist die Freiheit und das Geheimnis der Freiheit ist der Mut.
Das finde ich gut. Das könnte man vielleicht auch mal Hoss & Hopfs schicken. Da könnten wir noch mal eine Folge daraus machen denken.
Perikles Workshop machen.
Was möchtest du gewesen sein?
Ein guter Mensch.
Ich darf vielleicht auch mal der gute Mensch von Seeschuan, von Halbrecht lesen und jetzt kommt die Abmoderation. Also das geht so knapp zwei Stunden, das ganze Gespräch. Wir merken schon diese ganze Ton. Wir haben jetzt kein Bild, aber es ist dann auch etwas Wasser in den Augen, würde ich sagen, ganz deutlich. Nämlich Matze moderiert jetzt ab. Und wir haben jetzt über den Menschen Döpfner gesprochen. Wir haben natürlich auch diesen CEO kennengelernt, der Mensch, der da mit Vorurteilen zu kämpfen hat. Aber ich sag dir ein ganz, er ist auch Kritiker, ist also jemand, der schreibt, der ja auch jetzt keine Musikkritiken mehr seit Jahren, Jahrzehnten schreibt, sondern jetzt ja auch sonst immer interveniert. Hat sich ja jetzt auch nochmal in der Ost eingemischt. Können wir uns etwa denken, in welche Richtung. Jedenfalls hat jetzt Matze Hilscher sich gedacht, ich geb ihm auch noch was so mit auf den Weg. Das, weil man vergeht ja auch mal so in einer Karriere ein bisschen was verloren. Man vergisst das ein oder andere, wo man eigentlich herkommt, was man eigentlich auch liebt. Und wir hören uns das jetzt zum Schluss noch an.
Mathias, ich wünsche dir erstmal für dich den Mut, dass du deinem Talent auch zu schreiben, weil ich hab jetzt viel von dir gelesen, du kannst super, super schreiben. Das macht total Spaß, das zu lesen, was du schreibst. Ich wünsche dir den Mut, dass du dich irgendwann traust, das zu machen. Weil du bist auf diesem anderen Weg, hab ich das Gefühl, so auf eine Rolltreppe hat dich jemand gestellt, wer auch immer. Und du bist sie immer weitergelaufen, und du hast gedacht, du bist irgendwie ganz schön. Aber ich wünsche dir auf jeden Fall den Mut, und ich hoffe, dass die Menschen in deiner Umgebung weiterhin den Mut haben, dir zu sagen, was ist, und dass du den Mut hast, wirklich zuzuhören.
Danke.
Danke dir.
Schönen Schlusswunsch.
Ja, wünsche ich dir wirklich.
Danke, wirklich.
Ich kann sagen, dass es auch passiert. Kann sein, dass es auch passiert, sagt er am Ende. Wenn man sich mal wieder von seinem Besitz frei macht und wieder in die Sprache eintaucht, wieder ganz bei sich ist, beim Lindenbaum usw., dann ist man im tiefsten Kitsch angelangt und diese Verkitschung der eigentlichen Machtverhältnisse ist ein Dauerproblem, das wir haben, hier in sehr, sehr überschwitzter Form. Aber es ist die Realität, der wir uns dann Ende des Monats wieder stellen. Dann geht es weiter. Wir wollen noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass wir am 23. August auch wieder hier in Frankfurt live zu erleben sind, dann aber im größeren Saal in Bornheim ein paar Minuten von hier entfernt. Und wir freuen uns, euch dann wiederzusehen. Vielen Dank und schönen Abend.
Genau. Typischerweise kommt jetzt das Outro. Ich finde es aber leider einfach nicht. Von daher verabschieden wir uns so von euch.
Also, bis dann.